Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. For those of you who are black and attempted to be filled with hatred and distrust at the injustice of such an act against all white people, I can only say that I feel in my own heart the same kind of feeling. I had a member of my family killed, but he was killed by a white man. But we have to make an effort in the United States, we have to make an effort to understand,
感谢收听《一切皆历史》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。对于你们当中那些身为黑人、并因这种针对所有白人的不义之举而试图充满仇恨与不信任的人，我只能说，在我内心深处也有着同样的感受。我的家庭曾有一位成员遇害，但他死于一个白人之手。但我们必须在美国做出努力，我们必须努力去理解，
to go beyond these rather difficult times. My favorite poet was Aeschylus. He once wrote, Even in our sleep, pain which cannot forget falls drop by drop upon the heart until in our own despair, against our will, comes wisdom through the awful grace of God. What we need in the United States is not hatred. What we need in the United States is not violence and lawlessness, but love and wisdom and compassion
去超越这些颇为艰难的时期。我最喜欢的诗人埃斯库罗斯曾写道：哪怕在睡梦中，无法忘却的痛苦也会一滴一滴地落入心间，直到在绝望之中，违背我们的意愿，上天那可怕的恩典带来了智慧。我们在美国所需要的不是仇恨。我们在美国需要的不是暴力和无法无天，而是对彼此的爱、智慧与同情，
toward one another, a feeling of justice toward those who still suffer within our country, whether they be white or whether they be black. Let us dedicate ourselves to what the Greeks wrote so many years ago, to tame the savageness of man and make gentle the life of this world. I mean, we've had a lot of great oratory and rhetoric so far on this series. I mean, that's not bad, is it? That's Robert F. Kennedy again. It's the same speech with which we began our previous episode on the assassination of Martin Luther King. And there he is talking about the death of his brother, JFK.
以及对我们国内那些仍在苦难中的人们（无论他们是白人还是黑人）的公正感。让我们致力于实现许多年前希腊人所写下的愿景：驯服人类的野蛮，让这个世界的生活变得温和。我的意思是，到目前为止，我们在本系列中已经听到了许多精彩的演讲和辞令。我的意思是，这很不错，不是吗？这又是罗伯特·F·肯尼迪。这就是我们在上一集关于马丁·路德·金遇刺事件开头时播放的同一场演讲。当时他在谈论他哥哥、也就是约翰·F·肯尼迪的死。
And today's episode, Dominic, is about another assassination. It's about the assassination of Robert Kennedy. Yes. So that was, as you said, the 4th of April. That's the end of that speech he gives in Indianapolis. So he's in this very mixed neighborhood, it's kind of sketchy neighborhood. He's on campaign. He's speaking to this audience.
而今天的节目，多米尼克，讲的是另一场暗杀。讲的是罗伯特·肯尼迪的遇刺。是的。所以，正如你所说，那是4月4日。那是他在印第安纳波利斯发表的那场演讲的结尾。当时他在一个非常混杂的社区，有点鱼龙混杂。他在进行竞选活动。他在向这些观众发表演讲。
And he is not dumbing down, is he? No. Oh my God. There are not many people talking now in the current presidential election. Can't imagine either Donald Trump or Kamala Harris bringing in Escalus. Not at all. Not at all. Not at all. Extraordinary that he does two things there.
而且他并没有把内容讲得浅显易懂，对吧？没有。天哪。在现今的总统选举中，已经没多少人会这么说话了。无法想象唐纳德·特朗普或卡玛拉·哈里斯会引述埃斯库罗斯。完全不会。完全不会。完全不会。他能在那里做这两件事，真是非同寻常。
So he hears that Martin Luther King has been shot. He stands up and he talks to the first time in public about his brother's death. I had a member of my family killed, but he was killed by a white man. He bears his soul. And then the fact that he thinks to reach for Greek tragedy and to end the speech by saying to this largely black audience in Indianapolis, let us delegate ourselves to what the Greeks wrote so many years ago, to tame the savageness of man and make gentle the life of this world. Incredible.
因此，他听到马丁·路德·金被枪杀的消息。他站起来，第一次在公开场合谈论他哥哥的死。我的家庭曾有一位成员遇害，但他死于一个白人之手。他袒露了自己的心声。然后，他竟然想到援引希腊悲剧，并在演讲结束时对印第安纳波利斯这群大部分是黑人的观众说：让我们致力于实现许多年前希腊人所写下的愿景，驯服人类的野蛮，让这个世界的生活变得温和。这太不可思议了。
And for anybody who says, you know, people have always moaned the politicians are getting worse. It's a myth that they're getting worse. Just look at that speech, which was given as you said, extempore. Yeah, amazing. Extraordinary moments. And that is the quality of this year, that terrible as it is, I mean, there are loads of impressive people and the powers of rhetoric and everything about it is so vivid. It's painted in such rich colours. It is. I mean, that book that we began the very first episode with, the book by the Sunday
对于那些总是抱怨政客们一代不如一代的人来说，政治家在退步纯属无稽之谈。看看那场演讲吧，正如你所说，那是即兴发挥的。没错，太惊人了。非同寻常的时刻。这就是当年的特质，尽管它充满了残酷，我的意思是，有大量令人印象深刻的人物，其间的辞令与一切都如此鲜活。它被描绘得如此丰富多彩。确实如此。我的意思是，我们第一集开头读的那本书，那本由《星期日泰晤士报》记者撰写的《一场美国式的苦情剧》。我的意思是，这个书名选得很好，因为它确实给人一种不可思议的抓马感。这些人物个性如此鲜明，在各自不同的道路上如此惹眼——我们稍后会讲到一些截然不同的人物，比如乔治·华莱士、理查德·尼克松，还有罗纳德·里根。但话说回来，在他们所有人当中，罗伯特·肯尼迪或许是最具“全彩色”感的一个人。而且他是一个迷人、复杂且充满矛盾的人物。是的。在罗伯特·肯尼迪的故事中，人们会觉得对于民主党人来说，
Times Journalist, An American Melodrama. I mean, the title is well chosen because it does feel unbelievably melodramatic. The characters are so bold, so striking in their different ways and we'll come onto some very different characters, George Wallace and Richard Nixon and indeed Ronald Reagan later on. But yeah, of them all, Robert Kennedy is the one who perhaps stands out as the one that's the most technicolor. And a fascinating, I mean, complicated, conflicted figure. Yes. There's a sense in Robert Kennedy's story that he is the great, for Democrats,
他是最伟大的沉没成本、最伟大的烈士、最伟大的“本可以成为”的人。深入挖掘这一点其实非常有趣：他能成为总统吗？那又意味着什么呢？所以让我们直接进入他的故事。简单勾勒一下他是谁。他出生于1925年，是肯尼迪家族的第七个孩子。他和他的哥哥杰克一样，上过寄宿学校、哈佛大学，但他有点像配角，或者确切地说是第七号配角。所以他不是那种被寄予厚望的男孩。他父亲为他安排了一份工作，老板竟然是约瑟夫·麦卡锡，那个狂热的“打压红党”分子。
he's the great loss leader, the great martyr, the great what might have been. And it's actually really interesting to dig into that to see, could he become president and what would that have meant? So let's just get straight into his story. Give a very quick sketch of who he is. So he was born in 1925, he's the seventh of the Kennedy children. He, like his brother Jack, boarding school, Harvard, but he's sort of second fiddle or indeed seventh fiddle. So he's not a boy from whom great things are expected. His father fixes him up a job working for, of all people, Joe McCarthy, the great red baiter.
有很多麦卡锡。是的，麦卡锡太多了，汤姆。我觉得两个就嫌多。他在麦卡锡手下只干了六个月，但为此他在余生中一直饱受诟病。后来他去了一个专门调查行会的大型参议院委员会工作。也就是工会腐败。哦，不是体育运动。不，不。所以他在调查工会腐败。也就是吉米·霍法和卡车司机工会。正是在50年代末，他真正打响了自己的名气。
A lot of McCarthys. Yeah, too many McCarthys, I think, Tom. I think two is too many. He only worked for McCarthy for six months, but he always got grief about it for the rest of his life. He then went on to work for a big Senate committee that was investigating rackets. So Union corruption. Oh, not the sport. No, no. So he's investigating Union corruption. So Jimmy Hoffa and the Teamsters. And that's where he really makes his name in the late fifties.
这也是肯尼迪遇刺案阴谋论背景的一部分，对吧？有组织犯罪。有组织犯罪之类的。因为他对有组织犯罪非常严厉。然后他成为他哥哥的竞选经理。所以他基本上毕生都是他哥哥的副手，真的。正如我们之前讨论过的，杰克很有魅力，具有领袖气质，是个女人缘极佳、你会想找他一起去喝一杯的人。那是他的风格。实际上，他的朋友们总是叫他鲍勃（Bob），而不是
And so that's also part of the background to the JFK assassination conspiracy stuff, isn't it? Organized crime. Organized crime and everything. Because he's very tough on organized crime. Then he becomes his brother's campaign manager. So he's basically all his life, he's his brother's number two, really. And Jack is charming, as we've talked about before, charismatic, a ladies man, a guy you'd like to go for a drink with. That's his thing. Bobby, actually his friends always called him Bob rather than
鲍比（Bobby），但我们还是叫他鲍比，因为大家总是这么叫。他害羞、不友好、闷闷不乐，被认为有点清教徒作风——其实我觉得他确实是，他非常爱评头论足。他很难相处，浑身是刺，这对杰克来说太棒了，因为基本上鲍比就是那个“恶人”。所以他让罗伯特·肯尼迪担任他的总检察长，一位年轻的总检察长。我的意思是，正如人们所说，天哪，这是裙带关系，让自己的亲兄弟当总检察长。但实际上他干得很出色。他处理民权问题。他试图打击有组织犯罪，并且总是守在他哥哥身旁。比如，在古巴导弹危机期间，罗伯特·肯尼迪是杰克最主要的智囊，
Bobby, but we'll call him Bobby because people always do. He's shy, he's unfriendly, he's brooding, he's perceived as being sort of puritanical, I actually think he is, he's very judgmental. He's difficult, he's spiky and that's great for Jack because basically Bobby is the bad cop. So he makes Robert Kennedy his attorney general, youthful attorney general. I mean, as people say, God, this is nepotism, your own brother, attorney general. But actually he's good at it. He handles civil rights. He tries to crack down on organized crime and he's always at his brother's hand. So for example, in the Cuban Missile Crisis, Robert Kennedy is Jack's chief sounding board
因为他无比坚定、毫不动摇地效忠。他没有建立自己事业的野心，他只想当他哥哥的张伯伦。我也能问问他的妻子吗？可以，埃塞尔。埃塞尔，这个名字真好听。她有点像杰奎琳·肯尼迪。是的，有点像。我的意思是，她出身于一个非常非常富有的背景，是个社交名媛之类的人物。
because he is unflaggingly, unswervingly loyal. He has no ambitions to have a career of his own, he just wants to be his brother's Chamberlain. Can I also just ask about his wife? Yeah, Ethel. Ethel, which is a great name. And she's a kind of, there's a little bit of Jackie Kennedy. Yeah, a little bit. I mean, she's from a kind of very, very wealthy background, socialite, all that.
富有、社交名媛，埃塞尔·斯凯克尔。人们说，天哪，这基本上是天主教暴发户与新教老钱的结合。鲍比和埃塞尔的婚姻。他们有10个孩子，我认为，有争议的是，孩子太多了。我不认为你能真正全身心地投入到所有10个孩子身上。这进一步加深了肯尼迪家族的形象——你知道的，其中一个孩子今年参加了竞选，不是吗？是的，他参加了。
Rich, socialite, Ethel Skakel. People say, gosh, this is basically a union of Catholic new money and Protestant old money. The marriage of Bobby and Ethel. They had 10 children, which I think, controversially, is too many. I don't think you can properly devote yourself to all of your 10 children. And it contributes further to Kennedy's, who, you know, one of them has been running in this year's campaign, hasn't it? He has.
在退选之前。这是一场截然不同的竞选，我觉得这样说很公道。所以他将自己完全绑在了哥哥身上。这就是他为自己所求的全部。接着，在1963年11月，他接到了J·埃德加·胡佛的电话——他恨透了这个人：你哥哥被枪杀了，他的世界彻底崩塌了。当然，任何人都会为兄弟哀悼。这完全可以理解。但了解他们的人却被他悲伤的程度震惊、吓到、担忧。他穿丧服的时间远超所需。他实际上在办公室里为哥哥建了一座神龛。他不再
Before dropping out. A very different kind of campaign, I think it's fair to say. So he's tied himself completely to his brother. That's all he really wants for himself. Then in November 1963, he gets this call from J. Edgar Hoover, who he hates. Your brother has been shot and his world completely falls apart. Now, of course, anyone would mourn their brother. That's completely understandable. But people who know them are astounded, shocked, worried by the extent of his grief. He wears mourning clothes for much longer than he needs to. He effectively builds a shrine to his brother in his office. He stops
吃饭。他变得骨瘦如柴、沉默寡言、极具攻击性、离群索居。许多人说他基本上正在经历一场巨大的精神崩溃。但他用一种完全值得称赞的方式解决了这场崩溃：去加拿大爬了一座山，这座山恰好非常巧妙地叫肯尼迪山。是的。所以这座山是加拿大人以他哥哥的名字命名的，是北美洲未登顶的最高峰。他是和一个登山队一起去的，登山队对他印象极其深刻。他们说，看吧，这是一个瘦骨嶙峋的小个子，有着惊人的韧性和勇气，以这种闷闷不乐、面色严峻的方式去爬这座山。
eating. He becomes very thin, very silent, aggressive, withdrawn. Lots of people say of him he's basically having an enormous nervous breakdown. But he solves that breakdown in a completely commendable way by going and climbing a mountain in Canada, which actually is called Kennedy brilliantly. Yeah. So it was named after his brother by the Canadians, highest unscaled peak in North America. And he did it with a team of mountaineers who were incredibly impressed by him. Said, you know, this is a scrawny little guy of tremendous resilience and courage to climb this mountain
这基本上是他为了走出阴影必须做的事。你知道谁会赞同这一点吗？希腊人。不，约翰逊博士。他每当沮丧时，就会去伯明翰散步。我的意思是，这和去加拿大爬山不太一样，但理念是一样的。现在说到约翰逊博士，这就让我们想到了一个截然不同的约翰逊，也就是林登·约翰逊。太棒了。
in this sort of brooding grim faced way. It's basically the thing he needs to do to get closure. Do you know who would approve of that? The Greeks. No, Dr Johnson. Who, whenever he got depressed, he'd go on a walk to Birmingham. I mean, it's not quite the same as climbing a mountain in Canada, but it's the same idea. Now talk of Dr. Johnson brings us to a very different Johnson, which is Lyndon Johnson. Very good.
罗伯特·肯尼迪和林登·约翰逊互相蔑视，绝对是互相蔑视。所以林登·约翰逊一直都知道罗伯特·肯尼迪不想让杰克选他当副总统，他曾经在一次派对上对他说过，他使出了“约翰逊式施压”。他走到他面前说：鲍比，你不喜欢我，但你哥哥喜欢我。你嫂子喜欢我。你爸爸喜欢我，但你不喜欢我。你为什么不喜欢我？不过他们当时可没在男厕所里干这事。
Robert Kennedy and Lyndon Johnson despise, absolutely despise one another. So Lyndon Johnson always knew that Robert Kennedy didn't want Jack to pick him as Vice President and he once said to him at a party, he did the Johnson treatment. He went up to him and he said, Bobby, you don't like me, but your brother likes me. Your sister-in-law likes me. Your daddy likes me, but you don't like me. Why don't you like me? They're not doing this in the orinol though.
约翰逊可能在挥舞着他的宝贝。很有可能。罗伯特·肯尼迪讨厌这种谈话。他感到尴尬，然后灰溜溜地走开了。有时候他不得不举办晚宴，并且觉得必须邀请约翰逊，但难以置信的是，他总是把约翰逊安排在“失败者桌”。哦天哪。
You're probably waving his Johnson around. Probably. Robert Kennedy hates this kind of talk. He's embarrassed and he slinks away. And he sometimes would have to have these dinner parties and he would feel he had to invite Johnson, but unbelievably he would always put Johnson on the loser's table. Oh goodness.
他们就像哈布斯堡王朝一样。是的。就像埃尔多安妻子的粉丝索菲一样。没错。约翰和索菲坐在一端。事实上，在有一次约翰逊没去的派对上，罗伯特·肯尼迪的朋友们给他买的超级大礼物是一个林登·约翰逊的巫毒娃娃，因为他们知道他有多讨厌约翰逊。顺便说一句，约翰逊知道这一切，约翰逊对这种事心知肚明。
They like the Habsburgs. Yeah. Like Sophie, the fans of Erdanan's wife. Exactly. John is sitting at the end with Sophie. And in fact, in one party where Johnson doesn't go, the big present that Robert Kennedy's friends have got for him is a Lyndon Johnson voodoo doll because they know he hates Johnson so much. Johnson knows this by the way, Johnson knows all this kind of stuff.
所以约翰逊感到了极大的怨恨。因此，当肯尼迪被枪杀时，他们立刻就剑拔弩张了。RFK（罗伯特）对约翰逊搬进他哥哥的办公室愤怒不已。他随后特意在约翰逊的第一次内阁会议上迟到。他从不叫约翰逊总统，总是叫他“约翰逊”或者“那个男人”。当然，约翰逊也总是叫他“那个男孩”。所以他们之间完全失去了信任。
So Johnson feels tremendous resentment. So when JFK is shot, they're immediately, you know, a daggers drawn. RFK, Robert is livid that Johnson has moved into his brother's office. He then makes a point of turning up late to Johnson's first cabinet meeting. He never calls Johnson the president. He always calls him either Johnson or that man. Of course, Johnson always calls him that boy. So there's a total sort of breakdown of trust between them.
一方面，罗伯特·肯尼迪说，他说，约翰逊是个天生的骗子。我恨他。他太粗俗了。他太粗鲁了，甚至在没必要撒谎的时候也要撒谎。另一方面，约翰逊对他的速记员多丽丝·卡恩斯说：我是总统。我对他的兄弟忠心耿耿。我没做错任何事。又不是我杀了他。你知道的，基本上就是记录在案的这些话。是的。这似乎很不公平。原话是：“我一直在等我的轮到。鲍比本该等他的。”所以他们的关系极其恶劣，罗伯特·肯尼迪最终决定自立门户，竞选纽约州参议员，他也确实这么做了。一开始，他是个极差极差的竞选人。他不是一个
On the one hand, Robert Kennedy says, he says, Johnson is a born liar. I hate him. He's so vulgar. He's so coarse and he lies even when he doesn't have to lie. On the other hand, Johnson says to his kind of a manuensis Doris Kearns, I was the president. I had served his brother loyally. I'd done nothing wrong. I didn't kill him. You know, basically on the record. Yes. It didn't seem fair. Quote, I had waited for my turn. Bobby should have waited for his. So they have a terrible relationship and Robert Kennedy finally decides he's going to strike out on his own run for the Senate from New York, which he does. And at first he is a terrible, terrible campaigner. He is not a
好的演说家。我的意思是，他的声音听起来非常刺耳。所以，我不知道。我想我刚才已经表达出来了。你刚才是在试着表达这一点吗，汤姆？是的，我试了。很好。这很好。他基本上是在模仿他哥哥的一举一动。
good speaker. I mean, he has a very kind of reedy voice. So I don't know. I think I conveyed that. Did you try to convey that Tom? Yes, I did. Right. That's nice. He basically copies everything from his brother.
所以他模仿他哥哥的手势、说话方式、标志性的停顿，诸如此类。但他在竞选活动中双手发抖，然而他却是一个现象级人物。他的名气是其他任何政客都无法比拟的。这就是肯尼迪狂热。这就是肯尼迪狂热。就是这一切。是的，当然是。
So he copies his brother's hand gestures, his way of speaking, his Pinterest pauses, all of that kind of stuff. But his hands are shaking when he's out there on campaign, but he's a phenomenon. He's a celebrity in a way that no other politician can possibly match. So this is Kennedy mania. It's Kennedy mania. It's all that. Yeah, of course it is.
媒体也爱极了他。他们对他的报道极其甜腻、谄媚。他们沉浸在这种浪漫主义中，并在他余下的生命中一直如此。因此，他从1965年1月起成为参议员。尽管他不是总统，但他现在无疑是美国最大的政治明星。他每天收到成千上万封信件，每天有几十个演讲邀请。我必须说，他过着一种非同寻常的生活。比如，他的员工数量是国会民主党领袖的四倍。
And the press love him. They give him incredibly syrupy sycophantic coverage. They buy into the romance and they do that throughout the rest of his life. So he becomes Senator from January, 1965. And he is now, even though he's not the president, he is by far the biggest political star in America. He gets thousands of letters every day, dozens of speaking invitations every day. He lives an extraordinary life, I have to say. So he has four times as many members of staff as the leader of the Democrats in Congress.
他住在乡村庄园里。当人们在我们的俱乐部特别节目中问到阶级问题、阶级的历史以及美国是否有阶级制度时，他住在弗吉尼亚的一个乡村庄园里，家里有10个孩子、7只狗和一只名叫桑迪的海狮，海狮就住在游泳池里。然后他的孩子们，每个肯尼迪孩子都有一匹马或小马。他们还养了鬣蜥、浣熊、负鼠、凤头鹦鹉、鸭子、兔子、长尾小鹦鹉、仓鼠、鹅、鸡、豚鼠、蜥蜴、一头小牛和一只豹纹陆龟。我想我们可以安全地断定，这是一个动物园。是的。或者说是一个动物园。这不仅仅是个动物园，
He lives on this country estate and when people sometimes ask us in our bonus club episodes, we talk about class, history of class and does America have a class system? He lives in a Virginia country estate with 10 children, seven dogs and a sea lion called Sandy who lives in the swimming pool. And then his children, each Kennedy child has a horse or pony. They also have iguanas, raccoons, possums, cockatoos, ducks, rabbits, parakeets, hamsters, geese, chickens, guinea pigs, lizards, a calf and a leopard tortoise. I think we can safely say it's a menagerie. Yeah. Or a zoo. It's more than a menagerie,
对吧？这就像蒙特苏马的动物园。他们还有一大群——在肯尼迪的书里，他们称之为员工。坦白说，在英国，我们会称他们为仆人。保姆、家庭教师、女佣、厨师、秘书。我的意思是，他要什么有什么。所以他过着这种镀金般的生活，但我认为公平地说，他并不是一个快乐的人。他在国会山并不能真正融入其中。他不是那种自来熟、容易相处的人。自从他哥哥去世后，他也一直在经历这场巨大的中年危机。
isn't it? It's like Montezuma's zoo. And they've also got a huge team of, now in the Kennedy books, they call them staff. In Britain, to be frank, we would call them servants. Nannies, governesses, maids, cooks, secretaries. I mean, he wants for nothing. So he has this kind of gilded life, but I think it's fair to say he's not a happy man. He doesn't really fit in on Capitol Hill. He's not a hail fellow, well-met kind of character. He's also been having this gigantic midlife crisis since his brother died.
这就是他发现希腊悲剧的时候吗？正是如此。所以杰奎琳，杰奎琳·肯尼迪送给了他——你知道的，她自诩为读书人和文人。哦，她热爱希腊人。她喜欢希腊。她确实如此。她送给了他伊迪丝·汉密尔顿写的书《希腊人的生活方式》。
And is this when he discovers Greek tragedy? It does. So to Jackie, Jackie Kennedy gave him, you know, she fancies herself as a reader and as a woman of letters. Well, she loves the Greeks. She likes the Greek. She does. And she gives him this book, The Greek Way by Edith Hamilton.
她还说，哦，你可以尝试读一点加缪，或者读一点丁尼生这类的。他基本上是在经历一场迟来的青春期，因为他极其热爱某种存在主义。他总是对人抛出加缪之类的名言，这种行为如果出自一个16岁少年之口会非常讨人喜欢。而出自一个快40岁、甚至刚过40岁的人之口，你就会挑起眉毛了：加缪？真的吗？
And she also says, oh, you could try reading a bit of Camus, or read a bit of Tennyson or this. And he's basically having a delayed adolescence because he absolutely loves kind of existentialism. He's always giving people quotes from Camus and stuff in a way that from a 16 year old would be very endearing. From a man in his kind of, you know, late thirties, early forties, you're going to raise an eyebrow. Gamu, really?
你觉得这很有深度？埃斯库罗斯倒是经典的。是的，确实如此。当我说埃斯库罗斯（Escalus）时，我其实指的是埃斯库罗斯（Aeschylus）。你当然是的。但实际上，我不是想显得挑剔，因为他让自己成为弱势群体的拥护者，这种做法有其相当令人钦佩的一面。这是约翰·F·肯尼迪从来没有真正做过的事。
You find this very profound? Escalus is classic. Yeah, it is. And when I say Escalus, I actually mean Escalus. Of course you do. But actually, I don't mean to sound sniffy because there's something quite admirable about the way he makes himself the champion of the underdog. Now that's something that John F. Kennedy really never was.
约翰·F·肯尼迪有点太……也许有点太酷了，有点太完美主义了，你知道吗？但罗伯特·肯尼迪，他最喜欢的就是去加州见那些墨西哥农民工，和他们一起蹲在尘土里谈论他们的生活。（你知道的，他绝对热爱这一切）。他去了密西西比三角洲，那是美国最贫困的一些地区，他被那里的贫困深深震撼和触动。（你知道的，他和所有这些挨饿的孩子们合影，他对镜头说——如果你持愤世嫉俗的态度，可以说这有点像青少年的语气，或者你也可以说
John F. Kennedy was a bit too, maybe a bit too cool, a bit too polished, you know? But Robert Kennedy, he loves nothing better than going off to California and meeting kind of Mexican migrant workers and squatting in the dust with them and talking about their lives. You know, he absolutely loves all this. He goes to the Mississippi Delta, some of the poorest parts of the United States, and he's visibly shocked and moved by the poverty. You know, he's photographed with all these sort of starving children, and he says to the cameras, you could, if you were being cynical, say a slightly teenage way, or you could just say
这是一种令人钦佩的方式）。他说，我们究竟是个什么样的国家，每年花750亿美元造枪，却对像这样脸上爬满苍蝇的孩子们无动于衷。嗯，还有每年3亿美元花在狗身上。这话从他这个拥有私人动物园的人嘴里说出来，还真是挺讽刺的。是的，带着他的动物园、凤头鹦鹉之类的东西。但这本质上就是马丁·路德·金关于太空火箭和潜艇之类的话题嘛。没错，完全是。这就是同一个理念。这就是同一个理念。
a very admirable way. He says, what kind of country are we that we spend $75 billion a year on guns and we don't do anything for children like these who literally have flies crawling over their face. Well, and $3 billion a year on dogs. That's rich coming from him with his zoo. Yeah, with his menagerie and his cockatoos and things. But that is essentially the Martin Luther King lines about space rockets and submarines and things. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. It is the Same idea. It is the same idea.
他有一个计划，要向纽约一个非常萧条的地区——贝德福德-史岱文森（Bedford Stuyvesant）倾注资金。他基本上想让所有富有的朋友建立各种项目，来解决住房和工作问题。他去了南非，那个实行种族隔离的南非，在开普敦大学发表演讲。有没有哪位研究20世纪60年代美国的顶尖历史学家写过这个？
He has a scheme to pour money into a very depressed part of New York, Bedford Stuyvesant. He wants to basically get all his rich friends to set up projects and things, to have a housing and jobs and stuff. He goes off to South Africa, apartheid South Africa, to give a speech at the University of Cape Town. And has any leading historian of 1960s America written about this?
你知道吗？在他们职业生涯的这个阶段。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢。非常好。干得漂亮。这是我的硕士论文主题。而现在的悲剧是，我不知道把它弄丢到哪去了。
Do you know what? So this point in their career. Thank you, Tom. Thank you. Very nice. Very nicely done. This was the subject of my master's thesis. And the tragedy now is that I don't know where I've lost it.
肯尼迪家族经历的悲剧还不够多吗？我知道。那是稍微有点互联网之前的事了。我是用文字处理器写的，你知道那种机器。我想它可能在阁楼里的某个地方、以某种形式存在着，但我不知道怎么才能把它找回来。总之，我当时以此写的硕士论文。好吧，等他们建立“多米尼克·桑德布鲁克图书馆”的时候。那正是会发生的事。其余的在哪？历史就在那里。希望他们能找到它。这是一个图书馆。我想是个游客中心。希望他们能找到它。我认为这是一个“一切皆历史”游客中心。
Have the Kennedys not suffered enough tragedies? I know. It was kind of pre slightly pre internet. I wrote it on like a word processor, you know, one of those kinds of machines. And I think it may be in the attic in some way, in some form, but I don't know how it would be possible to retrieve it. Anyway, I did my master's thesis on this. Well, when they set up the Dominic Sandbrook Library. That's exactly what will happen. Where's the rest? It's history. Hopefully they'll find it. It's a library. Visitor Center, I think. Hopefully they'll find it. It's a Reshister's History Visitor Centre, I think.
互动的。在佛罗里达州奥兰多。是的，我拭目以待。卡斯特将军体验馆。没完没了。对，永远不会结束。那个卡斯特体验馆开多久了？有一个多月了吧。
Interactive. In Orlando, Florida. Yeah, I look forward to it. The general Custer experience. It goes on and on and on. Yeah, never ends. How long has that Custer experience been in? Over a month.
哦天哪。然而法国大革命，我几秒钟就逛完了。当他在南非时，他发表了一场我认为非常、非常精彩的演讲：“每当一个人为理想挺身而出、或采取行动改善他人的命运、或向不公发起抗击时，他就会发出微小的希望之涟漪。这些涟漪从千百个充满能量与胆识的中心交织扩散，汇聚成一股电流，能够冲垮压迫与抵抗的最强悍之墙。”如果你是一个南非黑人，
Oh my God. And yet the French Revolution, I was in and out in seconds. When he's in South Africa, he gave, I thought, a brilliant, brilliant speech. Each time a man stands up for an ideal or acts to improve the lot of others or strikes out against injustice, he sends forth a tiny ripple of hope. And crossing each other from a million different centres of energy and daring, those ripples build a current which can sweep down the mightiest walls of oppression and resistance. That's very inspiring stuff if you're a kind of black South African
或者如果你是1966年南非的一名自由派白人学生，这绝对是极其鼓舞人心的内容。这种演说应对了当时环境的挑战。是的。它没有辜负南非当时那种骇人现状的残酷性。这种演说契合了时代的氛围，即60年代中期那股氛围。因此，到1967年左右，他觉得自己成了终极的60年代晚期风云人物。他留起了长发，换了更年轻的演讲撰稿人，我猜他某种程度上成了时代精神的象征。所以，当你阅读当时的报纸和专栏作家对他的评价时——比如写了《一场美国式的苦情剧》的那些《星期日泰晤士报》的家伙们：
or if you're a liberal white South African student in 1966. It's oratory that meets the challenge of the circumstances. Yes. That isn't inadequate to the horror of the state of play in South Africa. And it's oratory that meets the mood of the moment, the mood of the mid-60s. So by 1967 or so, he feels like the ultimate kind of late-60s man. He's grown his hair, he's got younger speech writers, he is sort of emblematic of the spirit of the age, I guess. So when you read what the newspapers and what columnists said about him at this point, so those Sunday Times guys who wrote an American melodrama,
他既随性又宿命，既愤世嫉俗又理想主义，天性冲动而习惯精算。《乡村之声》：他的一部分是个士兵、一个牧师、一个激进分子和一个橄榄球教练，但他又都不是这些。他是个政客。你知道的，这种报道称他是一个遗世独立的人、一个无法被定义的人物，他身上有种黑暗的特质，但也有某种非常浪漫的东西，这种说法到处都在重复。
he was gay but also fatalistic, cynical but idealistic, impulsive by nature and calculating by habit. The village voice, part of him was a soldier, a priest, a radical and a football coach, but he was none of these. He was a politician. You know, this kind of coverage that he is a man apart, that he's an undefinable figure, that there is something dark about him, but also something very romantic. This is repeated everywhere.
回到我们上一集讨论过的话题，这是一个崇尚“酷”的时代，特别是如果你还年轻的话。他酷吗？我的意思是，他是唯一一个算得上酷的政客吗？是的，他很酷。绝对的。他很酷。人们说他是——我知道这对于一个政客来说听起来有点傻，但当时人们说他是终极的存在主义者。哦，他肯定会喜欢这个，带着他的加缪什么的。没错。他当然喜欢这个。他每天都在通过行动来定义自己。人们会说
To go back to something we discussed in the previous episode, this is an era that prizes cool, particularly if you are young. Is he cool? I mean, is he the only politician who counts as cool? Yes, he is cool. Absolutely. He is cool. People say he's the, I know this sounds a silly thing to say about a politician, but people say at the time he's the ultimate existential man. Oh, he'd love that wouldn't he with his camo and everything. Exactly. Of course he loves that. He's defining himself every day through action. People say
这样的话。但他实际上在意识形态上相当模棱两可。没错。我本来想问，所有这些酷炫的存在主义内涵，在实际政策上到底意味着什么？还是说他只在乎营造氛围/逼格？我认为这是一个在1967年的美国注定不会被追问的问题。因为有些人会说，这一切意味着什么？你差不多可以说：哦，我想创造一个让更少儿童受虐待的世界。我们都同意，除了波尔布特或什么人之外，没人会反对这一点。但你在政策层面到底是什么意思呢？
that kind of thing. He's actually quite ideologically ambiguous. Right. I was going to ask what all this kind of cool existential stuff means in terms of actual policy. Or is he just about the vibe? This is a question I think that it's fair to say you were not really expected to ask in America in 1967. Because some people would say, what does all this mean? You can sort of say, oh, I want to create a world in which fewer children are tortured. We all agree, no one disagrees with that unless they're Pol Potts or somebody. But what do you mean in terms of policy?
实际上他非常模棱两可，部分原因是他有太多的政策助理和演讲撰稿人，他们分属党内的不同派别之类。是的。所以他们拥有那种向外扩散的希望。我的意思是，那意味着什么？比方说，就越战这个重大政策问题而言，这意味着什么？最初他是个反共鹰派。他是个冷战分子，你知道的，他完全支持这个。但他在60年代中期开始转变。他说：我已经改变了对轰炸北越的看法。为此他挨了不少骂。《芝加哥
And actually he's very ambiguous, partly because he's got so many policy assistants and speech writers that they're on kind of different wings of the party and whatnot. Yeah. So they have the hope that's rippling out. I mean, what does that mean? What does it mean, for instance, with regard to Vietnam, which is the big policy question? So originally he had been anti-communist hawk. He had been a cold war, you know, he was all for it. But he starts to shift in the mid-60s. He says, I have changed my mind about the bombing of North Vietnam. He gets a lot of grief from this. The Chicago
论坛报》甚至称他为“北越驻参议院资深参议员”、“胡志明在美国的特洛伊木马”。好吧。但这其中是否也夹杂着对LBJ（林登·约翰逊）的个人怨恨呢？这确实存在。不可否认。正因为人们这么说，他随后便沉寂了下来。他基本上不想让别人这么想。于是他保持沉默，但随后他等了几年，到了1967年春天，他又重新出山，并表示：听着，我们必须停止这种轰炸。我们必须进行谈判。我们必须在西贡建立一个联合政府并撤回我们的军队。这就是其他参议院鸽派所说的话。所以这
Tribune called him the senior senator from North Vietnam, Ho Chi Minh's Trojan horse in the United States. Okay. But is this also personal resentment of LBJ? Is that mixed in with it? That's there. There's no denying it. And because people say that, he then falls quiet. He doesn't want basically people to think that. So then he's quiet, but then he waits a couple of years and then by the spring of 1967, he's back on the case and he says, look, we've got to stop this bombing. We've got to have negotiations. We've got to have a coalition government in Saigon and withdraw our troops. This is what other Senate doves say. So it's
并不罕见。这基本上和尤金·麦卡锡之流所说的话完全一样。所以关于他“是否只是另一个政客”的问题——事实上他没有公开挑战约翰逊，恰恰表明他就是个政客，因为他几个月又几个月地一直在权衡。我是该参选呢？
nothing unusual. It's basically exactly the same as what somebody like Eugene McCarthy is saying. So the thing about, is he just another politician? The fact that he doesn't challenge Johnson suggests that he is because he's all for month after month. He's weighing up his options. Should I run?
还是不参选？最终他决定不参选。然后，当然了，尤金·麦卡锡参选了，虽然他没有击败约翰逊，但在新罕布什尔州初选中重创了约翰逊。肯尼迪见状立刻说道：“哦，好吧，我现在正在重新评估我的立场。”于是很多人都觉得：“哦，他就是个普通的政客。”因此这就变成了——麦卡锡现在成了那个“酷”的人。当然。
Should I not run? And eventually he decides against running. And then of course, Eugene McCarthy runs and he doesn't beat Johnson, but he cripples him in New Hampshire. And immediately Kennedy says, oh, well, I'm now reassessing my position. And so lots of people are like, oh, he's just another politician. And so this is like McCarthy is now the cool one. Of course.
所以这就像披头士乐队和海滩男孩试图一决高下那种感觉。我猜是吧。如果你想这么比喻的话。对，如果你想往这方面靠的话。你知道的，谁才是街区里最酷的人？我的意思是，这在当时的美国生活中相当重要，对吧？确实如此。如果这就是你吸引的选民群体，而他们俩都在吸引那些
Yeah. So it's like the Beatles and the Beach Boys kind of trying to outdo each other, that kind of thing. I guess so. If you want to, yeah. If you want to go with that a little bit. Yeah. You know, who's the cool one on the block? I mean, this is kind of important in this period of American life, isn't it? It is. If that's the constituency you're appealing to and they are both appealing to the kind
追随海滩男孩之类的人群。这正是人们在谈论的话题——追随海滩男孩之类的人群。这正是人们所讨论的内容。所以在3月16日——也就是新罕布什尔州初选四天后，他来到了参议院的同一个党团会议室。这非常有卡梅洛特复兴的色彩，就是他哥哥宣布竞选总统时用的那个房间。他使用了他哥哥用过的同一句开场白。
of people who are following the Beach Boys or whatever. This is exactly the conversation that people have are following the Beach Boys or whatever. This is exactly the conversation that people have. So on the 16th of March, so that's what, four days after New Hampshire, he goes to the same caucus room in the Senate. It's very Camelot revival, the same room that his brother had declared his campaign for the presidency in. He uses the same opening line that his brother used.
他说：你知道的，我参选是为了对抗约翰逊，提出新政策，解决美国的贫困问题——那种可怕的贫困，结束战争，重申——引述我的话——“我们对这个星球道德领导权的权利”，这其实非常符合JFK的风格，但从一开始，人们就说出了你刚才说过的话：他这么做是因为他感到委屈，觉得麦卡锡抢走了他所有的支持者。《华盛顿邮报》写道：
And he says, you know, I'm running against Johnson to propose new policies, deal with the poverty in America, the terrible poverty, end the war, reassert, and I quote, our right to the moral leadership of this planet, which is very JFK actually, but right from the start, people say what you said, he's doing it because he feels aggrieved that McCarthy has run off with all his supporters. The Washington Post. Seeing the romance flower between his people, idealistic young people, and McCarthy, he moved to break it up with the ruthlessness of a Victorian father whose daughter has fallen
“看到自己的人——理想主义的年轻人——和麦卡锡之间绽放出了浪漫的火花，他以一个女儿爱上清洁工的维多利亚式父亲般的冷酷无情，前去把他们拆散。”许多人说他在这里表现得极其投机取巧。你知道的，他自己没有勇气迎战约翰逊，他让麦卡锡去干，现在他却要插一脚。肯尼迪本人无疑也这样觉得，因为他对此极其敏感、心有芥蒂，而且他是一个多年来一直以自己的勇气、作为存在主义者、作为“加缪会怎么做”、“希腊人会怎么做”而自豪的人。而实际上，他们绝对不会
in love with a dustman. And a lot of people say he's just being unbelievably opportunistic here. You know, he didn't have the courage to take on Johnson himself. He let McCarthy do it and now he's moving in. And Kennedy undoubtedly feels this himself because he's incredibly sensitive and sore about it, and he is somebody who's spent years basically priding himself on his courage, the existential man, what would Camus do? What would the Greeks do? And actually what they wouldn't have done
坐在家里拿着……嗯，其实他们或许还真会。也许他们真的会。所以他的计划，我猜，是熬过LBJ的任期——他原本假设会到1972年结束——然后再参选。而当时正处于LBJ尚未宣布放弃竞选的阶段。所以这也——公平地说——是他当时并没有真正与麦卡锡竞争的背景的一部分。他想跟LBJ较量一下。
is sit at home with their monatomy and let this guy... Well they might actually, actually they might have done. Maybe they would. So his plan, I guess, was to sit out LBJ's term of office, which he's assuming would end in 1972, and then run. And this is still the point at which LBJ hasn't announced he's standing down. So that presumably is also to be fair to him, part of the context that he's not really running against McCarthy. He wants to have a crack at LBJ.
是的，完全如此。而且那是他多年来一直在精心培养的一种竞争关系。是的。所以他可能会觉得：麦卡锡算老几，也配跟LBJ竞争？是的。如果非要有人把这家伙拉下马，那也得是我。是的，这倒也合情合理，但接着他就遇到了一个巨大的麻烦。是的，当然。
Yes, exactly. And that, that is a kind of rivalry that he's been nurturing for many years. Yeah. So he might feel, you know, who's McCarthy to run against LBJ. Yeah. If anyone's going to take him down, it's going to be me. Yeah, which is fair, but then he's got a massive problem. Yeah, of course.
因为LBJ说他不干了。在他宣布参选两周后，LBJ说：我出局了，我走了。现在他面对的是一个截然不同的前景。现在他面临着一个完全不同的对手，因为他依然有麦卡锡要对付。我们稍后会回到肯尼迪对阵麦卡锡的话题，你可以说这是现代美国政治史上最苦涩的权力斗争之一。但同时，他还得面对约翰逊的副总统——休伯特·汉弗莱。既然约翰逊退出了，休伯特·汉弗莱基本上就要继承约翰逊的政治机器了。
Cause LBJ says he's not running. Two weeks after he's declared, LBJ says, I'm out, I'm gone. Now he's got a very different prospect. Now he's facing a very different opponent because he's still got McCarthy. And we'll come back to Kennedy versus McCarthy, which you can argue is one of the most bitter struggles in modern American political history. But he's also got Johnson's vice president, Hubert Humphrey. Now that Johnson is out, Hubert Humphrey is going to basically inherit the Johnson machine.
现在汉弗莱是一个截然不同的人物。在所有这些人当中，汉弗莱是最自由派的。汉弗莱来自明尼苏达州，他有着无可挑剔的自由派履历：明尼阿波利斯市长、民权斗士，他曾是许多民权立法的主要起草人之一。不幸的是对他的情况而言——我的意思是，我无法不用这种词，汤姆，这是一个非常符合汤姆·霍兰风格的描述：自1964年以来，他一直是LBJ的太监，作为副总统，LBJ一直在驯服他、不断羞辱他。休伯特·汉弗莱可不是那种会在公共厕所里亮出自己宝贝的人。
Now Humphrey is a very different character. Of all of these men, Humphrey is the most liberal. Humphrey's from Minnesota, he had an impeccable liberal record, mayor of Minneapolis, champion of civil rights, he'd been one of the key authors of a lot of the civil rights legislation. Unfortunately for him, he's been, I mean, I can't, there's no other way of putting it, Tom, a very Tom Holland friendly description. He's been LBJ's eunuch since 1964 as vice president. LBJ has tamed him and humiliates him constantly. Huber-Hunfer is not a man who would expose himself in a public toilet.
是的，他不会在男厕所里甩他的那话儿。他才不会。他看起来是个好人。他看起来是个很好的人。是的，他是个好人。我想他是个好人。人们后来评价说，他某种程度上——据说他对家人并不是特别好，因为他总是在外面竞选，从来没时间陪他们。但我的意思是，这就是当政客的本性吧。而且他的中间名是贺拉斯（Horatio），对吧？是的。
Yeah, he wouldn't swing his dick in the urinal. He would not. He seems a nice man. He seems a very nice man. Yeah, he's a nice man. I think he is a nice man. People said afterwards he's sort of, apparently wasn't terribly nice to his family because he was always off campaigning and never had any time for them. But I mean, that's the nature of being a politician, I suppose. And his middle name is Horatio, isn't it? Yeah.
休伯特，他后来会被吉米·卡特介绍为——那是叫什么来着？休伯特·贺拉斯·霍恩布洛尔（Hubert Horatio Hornblower）。这基本上就不是介绍。这是吉米·卡特在民主党全国代表大会上的悼词。他说他是多么伟大的一个人：休伯特·贺拉斯·霍恩布洛尔。是的。那是……拿破仑战争时期的英雄纳尔逊式的人物。
Hubert, he will subsequently be introduced by Jimmy Carter as, what is it? Hubert Horatio Hornblower. Which is essentially not introduced. It's Jimmy Carter's eulogy at the democratic convention. He says what a tremendous man he was. Hubert Horatio Hornblower. Yeah. The hero of the, um, the Palaeonic war Nelsonian.
是的。如果你想约会——我的意思是，关于吉米·卡特有很多很多美好的赞誉，但公平地说，他绝对不是一个拥有非凡政治演说才华的人。是的。是的。没错。
Yeah. If you ever want to date, I mean, there's a lot, there's a lot of nice things to be said about Jimmy Carter, but he's not, I think it's fair to say a man of enormous political, oratorical. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. Right.
休伯特·汉弗莱，或者如果你喜欢的话，叫他休伯特·贺拉斯·霍恩布洛尔。我们叫他霍恩布洛尔吧。那样有趣得多。他在党内机器、工会、工会组织、城市大佬以及所有这类群体中拥有极其庞大的支持。基本上，如果你是民主党人并且党龄超过五年左右，你就会爱死休伯特·汉弗莱。他就像是——你知道的，终极的党内乖乖仔。按照这个体制的运作方式，你根本不需要去参加初选。所以他不会去——事实上，他要跑去参加很多初选已经太迟了。他可以直接收割党代表票并成为党内提名人，而且基本上没人真正恨他。
Hubert Humphrey or Hubert Horatio Hornblower, if you prefer. Let's call him Hornblower. It's much more fun. He's massively popular with like the party machine, with the trade unions, the labour unions, the city bosses, all of those kinds of people. Basically, if you're in the Democratic party and you've been there for more than about five years, you love Hubert Humphrey. He's like, you know, the ultimate party man. And the way that the system works, you don't need to run in the primaries. And so he's not going to, in fact, he's too late to run a lot of them. He can hoover up the delegates and become the party nominee and nobody really hates him.
他某种程度上是所有人的第二选择。这倒也行。我能问问关于他的事吗？可以。他对越战的立场是什么？因为我没记错的话，基本上他相当反对越战，但因为他是LBJ的副总统，所以他这一路都在咬紧牙关保持沉默？完全正确。
He's kind of everybody's second choice. And that's fine. Can I just ask you about him? Yeah. What is his take on Vietnam? Because am I right that basically he's pretty against it, but because he's LBJ's vice president, he's been holding his tongue the whole way through. Exactly.
就是这样。而且LBJ不信任他，认为他在越战问题上立场不稳。确实如此。完全、完全正确。所以可怜的休伯特·汉弗莱——如果他不是副总统的话，他毫无疑问会是鸽派之一、是对这场战争的批评者之一。但因为他是副总统且忠心耿耿，他永远不会跟约翰逊决裂。而且他一直默默隐忍、咬紧牙关。
That's exactly it. And LBJ mistrusts him, thinks he's unsound on Vietnam. He does. That's exactly, exactly right. So poor old Hubert Humphrey, who would undoubtedly have been one of the doves, one of the critics of the war, if he'd not been vice president, because he's vice president and he's really loyal, he will never break with Johnson. And he's been quiet, biting his tongue all this time.
即使现在作为候选人，他也不愿与约翰逊决裂，因为他是约翰逊的副总统，他不想疏远对方。所以他处境非常艰难。当然，麦卡锡也还在周围晃荡。现在麦卡锡的表现绝对是精彩绝伦。他说：本以为参选只是为了掀起一点波澜，现在我觉得其实我能当总统。我挺喜欢这份工作的。他公开宣称：当总统每天只需要花两小时工作，我觉得对国家最好的安排是把
And even now as the candidate, he won't break with Johnson because he's Johnson's vice president and he doesn't want to alienate him. So he's in a very difficult position. McCarthy is also still hanging around, of course. Now McCarthy is behaving absolutely splendidly. He says, having thought I would run just to basically cause a bit of a stir, I now think actually I will be president. I do quite like the job. He says publicly, I think it would take me two hours a day of work to be president and I think it would be best for the country if I spent
剩下的时间用来读诗。你知道吗？我会投他一票。由于他针对LBJ的这场竞选，他现在成了媒体的心头肉，是自由派舆论的宠儿，一大堆名流纷纷为他站台，保罗·纽曼、达斯汀·霍夫曼。我还读到斯特拉文斯基也支持他。他还活着吗？斯特拉文斯基当时都一千岁了吧。另一件事是，你简直无法用语言来形容他有多么痛恨罗伯特·肯尼迪。他绝对是鄙视他。他说，首先，他说，罗伯特·肯尼迪是个懦夫。他说，肯尼迪的那帮人——引述他的原话，这是一句非常棒的台词：“他们愿意
the rest of the time reading poetry. Do you know, I'd vote for him. He's now the darling of the press because of this campaign against LBJ, he's the darling of liberal opinion, he's got loads of celebs turning out for him, Paul Newman, Dustin Hoffman. Stravinsky I read. Is he still around? Stravinsky at the age of a thousand. The other thing is you cannot put into words how much he hates Robert Kennedy. He absolutely despises him. He says, first of all, he says, Robert Kennedy is a coward. He says, the Kennedy people were, and I quote, this is a very good line, they were willing
其余的时间都在读诗。你知道吗，我会投他一票。由于这次针对约翰逊总统的竞选活动，他现在成了媒体的宠儿，他是自由派舆论的宠儿，有大批名人为他站台，保罗·纽曼、达斯汀·霍夫曼。我还听说有斯特拉文斯基。他还在吗？斯特拉文斯基都一千岁了。另一件事是，你无法用言语形容他有多么恨罗伯特·肯尼迪。他简直鄙视透顶。他说，首先，他说，罗伯特·肯尼迪是个懦夫。他说，肯尼迪的人是——我引用原话，这是一句非常精彩的话——他们愿意
to stay up on the mountain and light signal fires and bonfires and dance in the light of the moon, but none of them came down. I tell you, I was a little lonely in New Hampshire. I walked alone." Now, when Robert Kennedy hears this, he's steamed coming out of rage coming out of his ears, he also says Kennedy is a wimp. Quote, he plays touch football. I play football. He plays softball. I play baseball. He skates in Rockefeller Center. I play hockey. And then my favorite line, which leads me to believe that he would actually have been a very good presenter on the rest is history. This is very rest is history vibe. He says Kennedy is thick. I got an A in economics and Bobby only got a C. Imagine saying that.
留在山上，点起信号火和篝火，在月光下跳舞，但他们谁也没下来。我告诉你，我在新罕布什尔州时有点孤独。我独自散步。”现在，罗伯特·肯尼迪听到这话时，气得七窍生烟，他还说肯尼迪是个懦夫。原话是：“他踢触地橄榄球。我踢橄榄球。他打垒球。我打棒球。他在洛克菲勒中心溜冰。我打冰球。”然后是我最喜欢的一句话，这让我相信他其实很适合担任《历史余音》的主持人。这非常有《历史余音》的风格。他说肯尼迪脑子笨。我经济学得了A，而鲍比只得了C。想象一下说出这种话。
Imagine going around saying that. That's exactly what I would do actually if I ran for president. I'd go in with my GCSE results. So it's a shame that McCarthy ended up disliking you so much when you had so much in common. I think we had so much in common. I think there was only room really for one of us. I think that was the thing. Well, like McCarthy and Kennedy. And Kennedy. The interesting thing, so do you want to hear about my discovery? Yes. So this is your archival discovery. Yeah, my discovery. And what the tragic thing thing is I made this discovery and I wrote about it
想象一下到处说这种话。实际上，如果我竞选总统，我就会这么做。我会带着我的GCSE成绩单去。所以，麦卡锡最后那么讨厌你，而你们俩又有那么多共同点，这真是一种遗憾。我觉得我们有很多共同点。我觉得这里其实只容得下我们中的一个。我想这就是问题所在。嗯，就像麦卡锡和肯尼迪。还有肯尼迪。有趣的是，你想听听我的发现吗？想听。所以这是你的档案发现。对，我的发现。而悲剧在于，我有了这个发现，并写了关于它的文章，
and nobody cared or has ever acknowledged it. This is your chance to make amends for that. I discovered in Hubert Humphrey's papers that Hubert Humphrey was secretly funding McCarthy's campaign. That is a bombshell. Bombshell. Was channeling money to McCarthy's campaign because there's all these... I mean, that's a properly genuine revelation. There's messages from Go Between saying McCarthy will need more money in Oregon. McCarthy says
却没有人关心过，也从未有人承认过。这是你弥补这一遗憾的机会。我在休伯特·汉弗莱的文件中发现，休伯特·汉弗莱曾秘密资助麦卡锡的竞选。这真是一个重磅炸弹。重磅炸弹。一直在向麦卡锡的竞选活动输送资金，因为有所有这些……我的意思是，这是一个货真价实的重大爆料。有中间人的消息说麦卡锡在俄勒冈州需要更多资金。麦卡锡说
hold off on the money. He can deal with Bobby for us. Because McCarthy and Humphrey had been pals in Minnesota. And I also found a letter in George McGovern's papers from McCarthy's campaign manager. And he says, I was literally handed envelopes of cash by one of Humphrey's backers. So there you go. Isn't that interesting? That is interesting. Robert Kennedy faces this real uphill struggle.
暂缓给钱。他可以为我们对付鲍比。因为麦卡锡和汉弗莱在明尼苏达州时曾是好友。而且我还乔治·麦戈文的文件中发现了一封来自麦卡锡竞选经理的信。信中说，我确实亲手接过了汉弗莱支持者之一给的一信封现金。所以你看。这难道不有趣吗？这确实有趣。罗伯特·肯尼迪面临着一场真正的硬仗。
He's got Hubert Humphrey, who's doing all these backroom deals to get delegates. And he's got McCarthy saying he's going to go to see an economics. He's a wimp and a coward. Doesn't play ice hockey. Basically the only way he can get the nomination is he's going to have to overwhelm the convention and the delegates with his own celebrity, with his popularity. Kennedy mania. He will have to wage a kind of psychological campaign as much as a political one, loads of rallies, loads of emotion, revivalism, college campuses, people crying, shaking his hand.
他有休伯特·汉弗莱，在暗地里搞各种交易来争取代表；还有麦卡锡，说他要去学经济学。说他是个懦夫和胆小鬼。不打冰球。基本上，他要想获得提名的唯一方法，就是用他自己的名气、他的受欢迎程度，即肯尼迪狂热，来压倒大会和代表们。他将不得不发起一场既是政治性的、更是心理学的战役，举行大量的集会、充满大量的情感、复兴主义式的活动，在大学校园里，人们哭泣着与他握手。
He'll campaign in the primaries, win as many primaries as he can and go to the convention and say to the delegates, come on, look how popular I am, you've got to pick me, but there's a huge risk and it's a physical risk because for everybody who loves Robert Kennedy, there is somebody who loathes him. No politician in America, I think it's fair to say, is as hated. And who are the haters? On the right? On the right. Or fellow liberals or what? I would say mainly on the right and people who are more conservative or more square by
他将在初选中四处奔走，尽可能多地赢得初选，然后去到党代会，对代表们说：“来吧，看看我有多受欢迎，你们必须选我。”但这里面存在着巨大的风险，而且是人身安全的风险，因为每一个热爱罗伯特·肯尼迪的人，都有一个恨他入骨的人。我认为可以公平地说，美国没有任何一个政治家像他这样招人恨。而那些恨他的人是谁？右翼人士吗？右翼人士。还是同为自由派的人，或者别的什么？我想主要是在右翼，以及那些在性格上更保守、更古板的人当中。
temperament. So people who say, who don't like, who resent his wealth, they resent his celebrity and his charisma. People who are not young or poor or black or marginalised. People to whom he is not the answer to disorder, but the embodiment of it. There have always been a lot of people who didn't like the Kennedy faction, who regard them as arrogant and overbearing and all of that. They loathe Robert Kennedy with a white-hot passion. He's getting a lot of death threats. Ethel, who you mentioned, his wife, is terrified that he will be shot.
所以，那些不喜欢、怨恨他的财富、怨恨他的名望和个人魅力的人。那些并非年轻、贫穷、黑人或边缘化的人。在他们眼里，他不是社会混乱的解药，而是混乱的化身。一直有很多人不喜欢肯尼迪家族，认为他们傲慢、专横等等。他们以炽热的激情痛恨罗伯特·肯尼迪。他收到了很多死亡威胁。你刚才提到的他的妻子埃塞尔，非常害怕他会被枪杀。
And it is clear that there are a lot of people who would welcome him being shot. When he announces his candidacy, a veteran columnist with the very American name of Westbrook Pegler, who's a columnist, it's fair to say on the very far right, writes, with luck, some white patriot of the Southern Tier will spatter his spoonful of brains in public premises before the snow flies. Wow. Yeah. Goodness, that's printed.
显而易见，有很多人会欢迎他被枪杀。当他宣布参选时，一位资深专栏作家、拥有非常美国化名字的韦斯特布鲁克·佩格勒——可以公平地说，他是一位极右翼专栏作家——写道：“碰碰运气吧，某个南方分层的白人爱国者会在下雪前，在公共场所把他的那勺脑浆打出来。”哇。是的。天哪，这居然被刊登出来了。
Yeah, that's what he thinks. And there are people who absolutely think that. People say that political discourse today is toxic, but I mean, can't imagine that being run in the newspaper today. Do you know what J. Edgar Hoover's partner, Clyde Tolson, said? He says it much more pithily. He says, I hope someone shoots and kills that son of a bitch. Well, I think probably we should take a break at that point. And when we come back, we'll find out whether
是的，这就是他的想法。确实有人这么想。人们说今天的政治话语充满毒性，但我的意思是，无法想象今天还会有报纸发表这种言论。你知道J·埃德加·胡佛的搭档克莱德·托尔森是怎么说的吗？他说得要简练得多。他说：“我希望有人开枪打死那个王八蛋。”嗯，我想我们大概应该在那时休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会知道
Clyde Tolson's wish comes true. RFK! RFK! RFK! And then Kennedy was there. His teeth gleamed startlingly white in the television lights and his tanned skin glowed. He looked as he sometimes did, more vital, more handsome than any film star, the personification of brilliance and success. This last political moment went beyond politics. Kennedy was at once broker of power, magic leader, desired sexual object, protagonist of aspirations, liberator and hero. So that's the book by the three Sunday Times journalists, an American melodrama that we've been referring to quite a lot over the course of this series. And the book is describing the scene in the Ambassador Hotel in Los Angeles, just moments
克莱德·托尔森的愿望是否成真了。RFK！RFK！RFK！接着肯尼迪就在那里了。在电视灯光的照射下，他的牙齿闪烁着耀眼的白光，晒黑的皮肤散发着光芒。有时他看起来比任何电影明星都更有活力、更英俊，简直就是辉煌和成功的化身。这最后的政治时刻超越了政治。肯尼迪既是权力的经纪人、具有魔力的领袖、令人渴望的性对象、抱负的主角，也是解放者和英雄。这就是三位《星期日泰晤士报》记者的书，一本美国情景剧，我们在整个系列中经常提到这本书。这本书描述了洛杉矶大使酒店的场景，就在
before the murder of Bobby Kennedy. And so Dominic, we will be building up to that dramatic night in California through the second half of the episode. But before we get there, there's some twists, aren't there? Some turns? We love a twist and a turn. We do indeed. So we've got to get to the 4th of June, really to mid-April, because that's when King has been shot. There's the funeral, everything stops a little bit because there's been the riots, there's been all the kind of hullabaloo about the death of Martin Luther King. And then the campaign kind of restarts in earnest.
鲍比·肯尼迪遇刺前几分钟。因此，多米尼克，在节目的后半部分，我们将一步步推向加利福尼亚那个戏剧性的夜晚。但在我们到达那里之前，还有一些转折，不是吗？一些波折？我们喜欢转折和波折。我们确实喜欢。所以我们必须来到6月4日，实际上是4月中旬，因为那是马丁·路德·金被枪杀的时候。举行了葬礼，一切都稍微停顿了一下，因为发生了暴乱，发生了所有关于马丁·路德·金之死的喧嚣。然后竞选活动重新正式开始。
And don't forget what Robert Kennedy needs to do. Somehow he needs to see off McCarthy, he needs to sweep the primaries, and he needs to build up this head of steam that will take him to the convention and persuade people to switch from Hubert Humphrey to him. So the first primary is in Indiana and that's why he's in Indianapolis, of course, when Martin Luther King is shot. So Indiana is a tough state for Kennedy. It's a Midwestern state, but it's quite industrial. It's got a lot of steelworks, got lots of blue collar workers who are what were called in the jargon of
别忘了罗伯特·肯尼迪需要做什么。他必须设法击败麦卡锡，他必须在初选中横扫千军，他必须积蓄这股势头，带领他走向党代会，并说服人们从支持休伯特·汉弗莱转为支持他。所以第一场初选是在印第安纳州，这也是为什么当马丁·路德·金遇刺时他会在印第安纳波利斯。因此对肯尼迪来说印第安纳州是个难啃的州。这是一个中西部州，但相当工业化。这里有许多钢铁厂，有很多蓝领工人，也就是当时行话所说的白人族裔，
the time, white ethnics, meaning they are German or Polish or Irish or Italian or whatever. So these are not people who would instinctively be sympathetic to someone who's 10 children all have a cockatoo. No, exactly. It's traditionally been seen in Indiana as quite a conservative state. So Nixon had won it in 1960. It had once had the largest clan membership in America. And at the very bottom of Indiana, you're almost in the South. So it's tough for Kennedy and he's facing McCarthy. He's also facing, confusingly, the local governor who is standing as a stand-in effectively for Hubert Humphrey, Governor Branigan.
意思是他们是德国人、波兰人、爱尔兰人、意大利人或别的什么人。所以这些人不会本能地对一个拥有10个孩子、每人都养了一只凤头鹦鹉的人产生好感。不，确实如此。印第安纳州传统上被视为一个相当保守的州。因此尼克松在1960年赢了这里。这里曾拥有美国最大的三K党成员网络。而在印第安纳州的极南部，你几乎就到了南部。所以对肯尼迪来说这很艰难，他面对的是麦卡锡。令人困惑的是，他还面对着地方州长、实际上代表休伯特·汉弗莱参选的替身布拉尼根州长。
At first, Kennedy goes to the college campuses and he's mobbed by crowds and he's got, his hair is quite long and he's talking about poverty and all this stuff. And as his biographer Larry Ty says, actually this was a bad look because Indiana worried more about crime than poverty. He wanted a father figure, not a fifth beetle. So he's persuaded by his aides to change his look. He cuts his hair, he puts on cheaper suits.
起初，肯尼迪去到大学校园，被人群围得水泄不通，他的头发挺长，谈论着贫困和诸如此类的事情。正如他的传记作家拉里·泰所说，实际上这是一个糟糕的形象，因为印第安纳州担心的是犯罪而不是贫困。他们想要的是一个大家长，而不是第五个披头士成员。因此，在他的助手们的说服下，他改变了形象。他剪短了头发，换上了更便宜的西装。
He starts to brand himself the former attorney general. It's basically say tough on law and order. Yeah. I'm the Dick Tracy of the 19, of the late 19th century. Like Kamala Harris. Exactly. Like Kamala Harris. He's obviously, he's got loads of money because daddy's credit card is coming in for quite a, quite a pounding. So daddy's still, still all around, isn't he? Yes, he is. He's had a stroke. So he's kind of, he can't be saying a thing or do anything. He can just sign the checks. Except for sign the checks. Exactly. So he gives that famous Martin Luther King speech and actually he wins. So Indiana is one down and it got the result. He wins about four out of 10 votes. He wins the majority of the delegates and on election night, he says to
他开始将自己包装为前司法部长。这基本上就是在宣示对法律和秩序采取强硬态度。是的。我是19世纪末的迪克·特雷西。就像卡玛拉·哈里斯一样。没错。就像卡玛拉·哈里斯一样。很明显，他有大把的钱，因为爸爸的信用卡正在经历相当猛烈的刷卡。所以爸爸仍然无处不在，不是吗？是的，他确实在。他中风了。所以他某种程度上什么也说不了，什么也做不了。他只能签支票。除了签支票什么也做不了。没错。所以他发表了那场著名的关于马丁·路德·金的演讲，实际上他赢了。所以印第安纳州拿下一城，并得到了结果。他赢得了大约十分之四的选票，赢得了大多数代表的支持，在选举之夜，他对
his aides, this is great, I want to build, and I quote, a new coalition of Negroes and working class white people against the union and the party establishments. But can he do that? If you look at the Indiana results, he has a few glaring weaknesses. So first of all, I said a lot of people can't stand him. This is born out. Three out of every five people in Indiana do not vote for him. This is in the Democratic primary. And historians have really dug into these figures because this, you know, his fate is so fascinating to historians. And they've discovered that among white voters, he does really, really badly. And it's basically black voters that
他的助手们说：“这太棒了，我想建立，引用原话，一个黑人和工人阶级白人反对工会和党内建制派的新联盟。”但他能做到这一点吗？如果你看看印第安纳州的选举结果，他有几个明显的弱点。首先，正如我所说，很多人无法忍受他。这一点得到了证实。印第安纳州十分之三的人没有投他的票。这是在民主党初选中。历史学家们深入研究了这些数字，因为他的命运对历史学家来说太迷人了。他们发现，在白人选民中，他的表现非常非常差。基本上是黑人选民构成了他获胜的微弱优势。
are his margin of victory. He is locked into now this kind of core constituency of people who are quite poor, some of these kind of so-called white ethnic voters, black voters, Hispanic voters and so on, because he's the champion of the underdog. The question is, can he pivot from that towards the center ground later on? And the problem is if you've got an election year in which the cities are going up in flames, law and order is on everybody's lips, all the papers are full of crime and chaos and all of this stuff, it's going to be really, really difficult to do. So this makes him very different from his brother. John F. Kennedy had been the man of the center ground really.
他现在被锁定在这个核心选民群体中，这些人比较贫穷，包括一些所谓的白人族裔选民、黑人选民、西班牙裔选民等等，因为他是底层人民的斗士。问题是，他以后能否从这个群体转向中间地带？问题在于，如果你经历了一个城市陷入火海、法律和秩序挂在每个人嘴边、所有报纸都充斥着犯罪和混乱的选举年，这将会非常非常难做到。这使得他与他的哥哥截然不同。约翰·F·肯尼迪才是真正的中间路线人物。
Nothing you could really object to. Robert Kennedy has put himself way out on what you might call, I guess, the left. And it's quite hard for him to win over people who don't already agree with him. And you see this in the next contest. So this is in Oregon, 28th of May. Oregon, obviously it's in the Pacific Northwest. It's a small town farming state, very well-educated, very white, very progressive. Perfect for Eugene McCarthy.
没有什么会让人真正反对的。罗伯特·肯尼迪则把自己推到了你可能会称之为左翼的立场上。要赢得那些本就不赞同他的人的支持，对他是相当困难的。你在下一场较量中就能看到这一点。这就是5月28日的俄勒冈州初选。俄勒冈州显然位于太平洋西北岸。这是一个小镇农业州，受教育程度很高，白人人口居多，非常进步。对尤金·麦卡锡来说简直完美。
And Kennedy, when he gets there, he doesn't like it. He says to his aides, this place is like one giant suburb. Let's face it, I appeal best to people who have problems. McCarthy's in his element. He's kind of going to all these little liberal arts colleges and whatnot. They've got little bookshops, bookstores. Yeah, he loves it. Poetry sections.
肯尼迪一到那里就不喜欢它。他对助手们说：“这地方就像一个巨大的郊区。承认吧，我最吸引那些有麻烦的人。”麦卡锡则如鱼得水。他去所有这些文理学院之类的地方。那里有小书店。是的，他很喜欢。诗歌区。
Exactly. And he is, to use the vernacular, much loved by our former producer, Dom Johnson, he rinses Kennedy about Vietnam and about the Cold War. And he says, look, he was part of the people who got us into this mess, right? He was a Cold War hawk. He's part of the military industrial complex. That's a term that McCarthy's using a lot at this point. He's absolutely part of the military industrial complex. All his friends are in the military industrial complex. That's a term that McCarthy is using a lot at this point. He's absolutely part of the military industrial complex.
没错。而且，借用我们前制作人多姆·约翰逊的话说，他在越南问题和冷战问题上把肯尼迪数落得体无完肤。他说，瞧，他也是把我们拖入这个烂摊子的人之一，对吧？他是个冷战鹰派。他是军工复合体的一部分。这是麦卡锡此时经常使用的词。他绝对是军工复合体的一部分。他的朋友们都在军工复合体里。
All his friends are in the military industrial complex. Why would you vote for someone like this? Who is clearly part of the problem, not part of the solution. The result? McCarthy wins. 45 to 39%. The first time a Kennedy has ever lost a public election. And this is the news, that's the headline.
他所有的朋友都在军工复合体里。为什么要投票给这样的人？他显然是问题的一部分，而不是解决问题的一部分。结果呢？麦卡锡赢了。以45%对39%获胜。这是肯尼迪家族在公开选举中首次尝到败绩。这就是新闻，这就是头条。
The Kennedys are not invincible. They can be beaten. And this kind of guy who everyone was saying was a joke six months ago. They're not laughing now. Yeah. The guy who was talking about the Punic Wars, he's just wiped the floor with Kennedy. So what you have now is a situation where, Hubert Humphrey is still accumulating one of his delegates, by the way, but the left of centre of American politics is clearly
肯尼迪家族并非战无不胜。他们是可以被击败的。而这个六个月前还被所有人当成笑话的家伙。他们现在可笑不出来了。是的。那个谈论布匿战争的家伙，刚刚把肯尼迪打得落花流水。所以你现在面临的情况是，休伯特·汉弗莱仍在继续积累他的代表票，顺便说一句，但美国政治的左翼中间派显然
being divided in two. On the one hand, you have the suburban middle class, the university people, well-heeled, the Guardian readers of America. They are team Eugene McCarthy. And on the other hand, you have obviously the Camelot fan club, but you also have black voters, Hispanics, people who feel that they are, as it were, towards the bottom, the losers of society, if you like. They are Kennedy's people. He keeps hoping that McCarthy will drop out or will reach a compromise. McCarthy despises him so much, and of course has all this Humphrey money, that there's
被一分为二了。一方面，你有郊区中产阶级、大学知识分子、富有阶层、美国的《卫报》读者。他们是尤金·麦卡锡团队。另一方面，你不仅有卡米洛特粉丝俱乐部，还有黑人选民、西班牙裔、那些觉得自己处于社会底层、可以说是社会失意者的人。他们是肯尼迪的人。他一直希望麦卡锡会退选或达成妥协。但麦卡锡非常鄙视他，当然还有所有这些汉弗莱的资金支持，所以他
no way he's ever going to do that. So it's all going to come down to California. California's primary is on the 4th of June and California is massively important. It's just overtaken New York as the biggest state in the union. And also the eyes of the world are on it. Exactly. The Summer of Love, the hippies and all that. Exactly. But you've got Reagan too, haven't you? This is the great thing about California, it's 60s America and Mike Cosm. You've got the student protests in Berkeley, you've got riots in Watts, you have the white backlash in suburbia that propelled Reagan. So it's almost you can tell the whole story of 60s America through the state of California. California
绝不可能那么做。因此，一切都将取决于加利福尼亚州。加利福尼亚州的初选在6月4日，加利福尼亚极其重要。它刚刚超越纽约，成为联邦中最大的州。而且全世界的目光都聚焦于此。没错。爱之夏，嬉皮士等等。没错。但你也有里根，不是吗？这就是加利福尼亚的伟大之处，这里是60年代的美国缩影。伯克利有学生抗议，沃茨区有暴乱，郊区有推动里根上台的白人保守反弹。所以你几乎可以通过加利福尼亚州来讲述整个60年代美国的故事。加利福尼亚
also sends the most delegates to the Democratic convention, I think something like 174. So what is that about eight or nine times New Hampshire where McCarthy had started his campaign. The timetable of the primaries now is so compressed that there's basically a two week campaign. And it's one of the most anticipated and keenly followed primary campaigns in American history. Because what both candidates are doing is they're both doubled down on their appeal. McCarthy in the TV studios, very reasoned, very calm, goes to the college campuses quoting Catholic writers of the 1910s that no one's ever heard of. But I can't imagine that being popular with the freaks.
还向民主党全国代表大会派遣最多的代表，大概有174名左右吧。那大概是新罕布什尔州的八到九倍，而麦卡锡正是在那里开始他的竞选的。现在初选的时间表被压缩得如此紧凑，基本上只有两周的竞选期。这是美国历史上最受期待和密切关注的初选活动之一。因为两位候选人都在全力巩固各自的支持盘。麦卡锡在电视演播室里，表现得极其理性、冷静，去大学校园引用一些无人知晓的1910年代的天主教作家的作品。但我无法想象这会受那些嬉皮士的欢迎。
No, I don't think the freaks, not the freaks, but the sort of slightly squarer students, maybe only a little bit squarer, but students who are idealistic. Students who are dreamers. They like the idea of this romantic underdog, a cerebral, serious person, you know, who quotes, who writes poems and is interested in philosophy. But are the furry freak brothers, they're breaking for Bobby, are they? Well, so what Bobby does, his aides say to him, do you want to row back a little bit on going all in on these massive rallies in scruffy areas and things? Is this really a wise strategy? And he says, no, no, this is what I do. So he goes all in on massive rallies,
不，我想那些嬉皮士——不是嬉皮士，而是那些稍微有点古板的学生，也许只古板了一点点，但他们是理想主义的学生。那些有梦想的学生。他们喜欢这种浪漫的弱者形象，一个理性、严肃的人，你知道的，他引经据典，写诗并且对哲学感兴趣。但那些毛茸茸的怪胎兄弟们，他们会支持鲍比吗？嗯，所以鲍比的做法是，他的助手对他说：“你要不要稍微收敛一点，别一门心思去搞那些破旧地区的宏大集会之类的东西？这真的是明智的策略吗？”他说：“不，不，这就是我的作风。”所以他全力投入到大型集会中，
goes to poor areas of cities, he's got big black crowds. And one headline at the time said it was basically a contest between an evangelist and a philosopher. I think there's some truth in that. That captures the kind of temperamental difference. Of course, if you're a real freak, Tom, you wouldn't go to either, would you? I mean, do you go to political rallies if you're a... Stick it to the man. Yeah. By, yeah, spliffing up, taking LSD.
去城市的贫困地区，他有大量黑人群众。当时的一个头条新闻说，这基本上是一场福音传道者与哲学家之间的较量。我认为这有一定的道理。这抓住了他们性格上的差异。当然，如果你是个真正的怪胎，汤姆，你两边都不会去，对吧？我的意思是，如果你是一个……你会去参加政治集会吗？反抗体制。是的。通过，是的，抽大麻，嗑LSD。
A sign of how exciting the campaign is that they have a TV debate, which is actually quite boring because they don't really disagree about anything, which is watched by 32 million people. So a huge audience for a debate in one primary in one state among the supporters of one party. They have a disagreement about how they're going to break up the ghettos. Kennedy says you have to take jobs and housing and stuff into the ghettos. McCarthy says, no, that's kind of apartheid. You have to kind of break them up and then have an argument about that. Kennedy says, what, you're going to take all these black people and move them out into Orange County? It was very suburban, very conservative. And lots of people say,
这场竞选激烈的标志是他们进行了一场电视辩论。实际上这场辩论相当无聊，因为他们在任何事情上都没有真正的分歧，但却有3200万人观看。对于一个州的初选中某一个党派支持者之间的辩论来说，观众规模极其庞大。他们对如何瓦解贫民窟有分歧。肯尼迪说你必须把就业和住房之类的事情带进贫民窟。麦卡锡说，不，那有点像种族隔离。你必须先打破它们，然后就此展开争论。肯尼迪说，什么，你打算把所有这些黑人都赶到奥兰治县去吗？那里非常郊区化，非常保守。很多人说，
oh gosh, that's a terrible dog whistle. But actually what's so fascinating about this campaign, which is so embittered, so dramatic, is that it is pure vibes. So it's like the Roman Republic. It's totally the Roman Republic. I was thinking of this while reading about it just now, that what's the optimates and the populares? So the people who think they are the representatives of the old privileged class, restrained, sober, cerebral, and then the other people who they are the representatives of the old privilege class, restrained, sober, cerebral, and then the other people who are sort of part of the mob. Is that the distinction? Well, no, not quite, but yes, appealing over the heads of the traditional elites. Yeah, a sort of populist and a patrician.
哦天哪，这是一个可怕的政治暗号。但实际上，这场如此痛苦、如此戏剧性的竞选最迷人之处在于，它纯粹是一种气场。所以这就像罗马共和国。完全就是罗马共和国。刚才读到相关内容时我就在想，什么是优化派和平民派？所以，那些自认为代表了旧特权阶级的人，克制、清醒、理性，然后还有另一些人，他们自认为代表了旧特权阶级，克制、清醒、理性，而另一些人则是暴民的一部分。是这种区别吗？嗯，不完全是，但是的，越过传统精英直接向民众呼吁。是的，一种民粹主义者与贵族的对决。
It's about style rather than about, well, they're both elite. I mean, that's the whole thing. Well, which you could say about these two senators, right? Yeah. So it's a good parallel. So I think that is a good parallel. Anyway, we get to the last full day of campaigning, the 3rd of June. That day, Robert Kennedy traveled 1200 miles.
这更多关乎风格而不是关于……好吧，他们都是精英。我的意思是，这就是全部所在。好吧，你也可以这样评价这两位参议员，对吧？是的。所以这是一个很好的平行对比。所以我觉得这是一个很好的对比。无论如何，我们来到了竞选的最后完整一天，即6月3日。那天，罗伯特·肯尼迪行程达1200英里。
He went from Los Angeles to San Francisco, then back down to Long Beach to Watts to San Diego, then back to Los Angeles. Massive rallies, pressing the flesh. He's giving these speeches about his two big issues, which are the Vietnam War and poverty in America. He is absolutely shattered. His hands are covered with blood. They're very badly bruised. He's shaken so many hands. He's in fact been advised to stop shaking hands because he's literally shaking hundreds, if not thousands. I've never heard of that happening.
他从洛杉矶飞往旧金山，然后南下长滩到沃茨，再到圣地亚哥，最后返回洛杉矶。举行大规模集会，与民众握手。他发表了关于他关心的两个核心议题的演讲，即越南战争和美国的贫困问题。他已经精疲力竭。他的双手布满血迹。伤痕累累。他握了太多人的手。事实上，他曾被建议停止握手，因为他 literalmente 握了成百上千次。我从未听说过这种事。
Every day. Oh yeah. I mean- Hands bleeding because you're shaking hands so often. But think about it, if you see the footage of his rallies. Yeah, of course I see kind of reaching out and pumping in the Kennedy way, Camelot shake. Absolutely. But it's very different from his brother's rallies, which are much more controlled. These are, there's a frenzied, you know, very 1968, a frenzied frenetic atmosphere to this.
每天如此。噢，是的。我是说——手都握出血了，因为你握手太频繁了。但想想看，如果你看过他集会的录像。对，当然，我看到那种伸手出去，以肯尼迪的方式上下摇动，卡米洛特的握手方式。绝对是。但这与他哥哥的集会截然不同，他哥哥的集会受到的控制要多得多。这些集会有一种狂热的、你知道的，非常1968年风格的狂热而慌乱的氛围。
People screaming and shouting. It's hot, obviously it's California in June. You know, the whole thing is really overwrought. Chase Stadium vibe. Very much. Candlestick Park. Yeah. He's lost his voice.
人们尖叫呐喊。天气很热，显然是六月的加利福尼亚。你知道，整个场面非常过度亢奋。有烛台球场（Candlestick Park）的氛围。确实如此。烛台球场。是的。他已经失声了。
He's on the verge of collapse. His team are very worried now about the danger of assassination. They've had a lot of death threats. Ethel is very frightened. What's worse is they have terrible relations with the local police in California because the boss in Los Angeles, this guy called Sam Yorty, is not a Kennedy ally by any means. Their relations with the local police department, the LAPD, are very bad. The Kennedy people said the LAPD refused to help us. The LAPD guys said afterwards, actually the problem
他濒临崩溃。他的团队现在非常担心暗杀的危险。他们收到了大量的死亡威胁。埃塞尔非常害怕。更糟糕的是，他们与加利福尼亚当地警察的关系极其恶劣，因为洛杉矶的警长，这家伙叫萨姆·约蒂（Sam Yorty），绝对不是肯尼迪的盟友。他们与当地警察局（LAPD）的关系非常糟糕。肯尼迪的人说洛杉矶警察局拒绝帮助我们。洛杉矶警察局的人事后说，其实问题在于
was the Kennedy people were arrogant and they wouldn't cooperate with us. Kennedy's own biographer, Larry Tai, says, the truth is the candidate himself is part of the problem here. That he's given advice, be careful, don't maybe too visible. But of course he wants to be visible because the courage is such an important, proving his courage is so important. And to McCarthy as much as to anyone else, I suppose. Yeah, absolutely. It's so important to him.
肯尼迪的手下太傲慢了，他们不肯跟我们合作。肯尼迪自己的传记作家拉里·泰说，事实是候选人本人就是问题的一部分。他得到了告诫：小心点，也许不要太显眼。但当然他想引人注目，因为展现勇气是如此重要，证明自己的勇气是如此重要。我想，对麦卡锡来说也是如此。是的，绝对的。这对他太重要了。
What kind of presidential candidate hides away? Well, as we will see, Richard Nixon, but we'll get onto that later on. So the 4th of June polling day, if Kennedy loses, he is out. He cannot continue if he loses to McCarthy a second time. It's a cold day, unseasonably cold, the smog over Los Angeles. The Kennedy Maynard is staying at Malibu. They've been lent the beach house of the film director John Frankenheimer who made the Manchurian Candidate. Great conspiracy, political conspiracy thriller of course of the 1950s. Kennedy because he's exhausted he sleeps in late and then
哪有总统候选人藏着掖着的？好吧，正如我们将看到的，理查德·尼克松就是，但我们稍后再谈这个。所以6月4日投票日，如果肯尼迪输了，他就出局了。如果他再次输给麦卡锡，他就无法继续下去了。那天天气很冷，异常的寒冷，洛杉矶上空笼罩着雾霾。肯尼迪的团队住在马里布。他们借用了电影导演约翰·弗兰肯海默的海滨别墅，他曾执导过《满洲候选人》。当然，这是20世纪50年代一部伟大的政治阴谋惊悚片。肯尼迪因为精疲力竭，一直睡到很晚，然后
he goes swimming with his family. Son David is almost drowned and he dives in to rescue him, which is a very nice, very Kennedy behaviour, Tom. Unlike his younger brother, of course, Teddy Kennedy. Yes. Chappaquiddick notably failed to behave like that. That's true. That's harsh. That's harsh. But I can't argue with it. Anyway, they get back to the house. Thankfully nobody has died on this occasion unlike a chap critic. And the first reports are coming through. It's looking
他陪家人去游泳。儿子大卫差点溺水，他潜水去救他，这是一种非常美好、非常典型的肯尼迪式行为，汤姆。当然，这不像他的弟弟、特德·肯尼迪。是的。查帕奎迪克事件中著名地未能表现出这种行为。确实如此。这话说得真刺耳。真刺耳。但我无法反驳。无论如何，他们回到了房子里。谢天谢地，这次没有人死，不像查帕奎迪克事件。第一批开票结果传来了。情况看起来
quite good, but they're not certain. It's going to be very close. Frankenheimer, the film director, drives Kennedy into the city. He takes a very strange meandering route because he's going to avoid the crowds, which gets everybody very stressed, more stressed. They finally get to the Ambassador Hotel at about seven o'clock. So the Ambassador Hotel is on Wilshire Boulevard. It's in the middle of the great sprawl of Los Angeles and it's a city landmark. It had been built in the twenties and it was famous for this nightclub called the Coconut Grove, which was the ultimate Hollywood hangout. And Frank Sinatra was always there. Dean Martin.
相当不错，但还不能确定。选情会非常胶着。电影导演弗兰肯海默开车送肯尼迪进城。他走了一条非常奇怪的蜿蜒路线，因为他要避开人群，这让所有人都感到压力很大，压力更大了。他们大约在七点钟终于到达了大使酒店。大使酒店位于威尔希尔大道。它位于洛杉矶庞大的城市蔓延区的中央，是城市的地标。它建于20年代，以一个叫椰林（Coconut Grove）的夜总会而闻名，那是终极的好莱坞聚会场所。弗兰克·辛纳屈总是在那里。迪恩·马丁。
Yeah, all that kind of thing. But the whole thing is very faded now, right? We talked in the previous episode about Memphis. One of the things about late sixties America is that all these old places, these kind of art deco places. You wouldn't find Jim Morrison there. No, they're kind of faded and old fashioned. And this is very true of the Ambassador Hotel. Up he goes to suite 512. He's got all his aids, he's got banks of telephones, you know, the whole scene that you would expect from a Kennedy campaign. The polls close at eight o'clock and the returns are very slow to come in and they're studying the returns. As expected, McCarthy is piling up votes in the small towns and in the suburbs. He is clearly going to win Northern California, the area around San Francisco.
对，诸如此类。但现在这一切都显得有些黯淡了，对吧？我们在上一集中谈论过孟菲斯。60年代末美国的一个特点就是所有这些老地方，这些装饰艺术风格的地方。你在那里找不到吉姆·莫里森。不，它们有些破败和过时了。大使酒店确实如此。他上楼来到512套房。那里聚集了他的所有助手，摆着一排排电话，你知道的，这就是你对一场肯尼迪竞选活动的预期场景。投票在八点钟结束，开票结果非常缓慢，他们正在研究这些结果。不出所料，麦卡锡在小镇和郊区积攒了大量选票。他显然将赢得北加州，也就是旧金山周边地区。
Kennedy is doing really well with the black and Hispanic voters. The question is can he get enough of them in Los Angeles County to offset MacArthur's strength in Northern California. It's really nerve-racking for him and his team. The results are coming in very slowly. There's computers breaking down. It's a very, very familiar American election night scene. Finally, we get to about 11 o'clock at night. They get good news. They have won Los Angeles County very decisively. All that time spent on those rallies has been worth it. It seems pretty clear he's going to win a narrow victory, perhaps 46 to 42 percent. But that's enough.
肯尼迪在黑人和西班牙裔选民中表现非常好。问题是，他能否在洛杉矶县获得足够的选票，来抵消麦卡锡在北加州的优势。这对他和他的团队来说真是让人神经紧绷。开票结果来得非常慢。电脑频频死机。这是一个非常非常熟悉的美国选举之夜场景。最后，到了晚上11点左右。他们得到了好消息。他们以绝对优势赢得了洛杉矶县。花在那些集会上的所有时间都是值得的。情况看来很明朗，他将赢得一场微弱的胜利，大约46%对42%。但这已经足够了。
Narrower than he would have liked because it keeps McCarthy in. But he's now got the big mo. Well, or has he? This is the question. At this moment in his sweep, people are pouring over delegate counts. They cannot be sure exactly how the delegates are going to go at the convention. There's one delegate count that has shown to Robert Kennedy just before he died that is very bleak for him. They say Humphrey's on 994, you're on 524 and a half, I don't know how you can get half a
比他希望的要微弱，因为这让麦卡锡得以继续留下来。但他现在有了前进的势头。嗯，真的是这样吗？这就是问题所在。就在他取得胜利的这个时刻，人们正在仔细核算代表票数。他们无法确定代表们最终在党代会上会支持谁。就在罗伯特·肯尼迪去世前不久，有人向他展示了一份代表统计数据，对他来说非常惨淡。他们说汉弗莱拥有994票，你拥有524票半——我不知道你怎么能得到半个
delegates but there you go, and McCarthy on 204. There are others that are closer but he is still a long way behind Humphrey. Also the polls show counter intuitively to people who have drunk deep of the romance of the 60s. Humphrey is still by far the preferred choice of registered Democrats. They know him, he's the party man, everybody likes him. Kennedy only gets about a third of registered Democrats as their top choice. What's also a problem for him is the next primary is in New York. McCarthy is definitely not going to pull out. McCarthy has already held a massive rally in Madison Square Garden. He's got loads of promises of money from people in New York.
代表，但事实就是这样——而麦卡锡拥有204票。还有其他一些数据比较接近，但他仍然远远落后于汉弗莱。此外，民调显示，与那些沉迷于60年代浪漫情调的人的直觉相反，汉弗莱仍然是注册民主党人迄今为止首选的人选。他们认识他，他是党内根基深厚的人，每个人都喜欢他。只有大约三分之一的注册民主党人将肯尼迪作为他们的首选。对他来说另一个问题是下一场初选在纽约。麦卡锡绝对不会退选。麦卡锡已经在麦迪逊广场花园举行了一场声势浩大的集会。他从纽约人那里得到了很多资金承诺。
His aides are actually quite confident that he can do really well in New York, perhaps win it. So at that moment up in his suite, Kennedy is musing with his team, shall I make McCarthy an offer? Offer him Secretary of State. If he pulls out now and I become president, I hate McCarthy and he's treated me like with total contempt, but I will offer him this prize job if he pulls out, but will he go for it? Anyway, enough we have to go down and declare victory. He takes a few moments, he has a little cigar,
他的助手们其实相当自信他能在纽约表现得很好，甚至可能赢得纽约。所以在那个时刻，在他的套房里，肯尼迪正在和他的团队沉思：我要不要向麦卡锡开出条件？邀请他出任国务卿。如果他现在退选而我当选总统——我恨麦卡锡，他对我傲慢无礼、极度蔑视，但如果他退选，我会把这个重要的职位给他，但他会接受吗？不管怎样，够了，我们得下楼去宣布胜利了。他花了一会儿时间，抽了根雪茄，
he's sitting there on the floor of his suite, very Robert Kennedy, 1960, very groovy, cross legged on the floor, smoking his cigar. And what's even groover is that they then go down and sing Woody Guthrie songs. Yes. So he goes downstairs to the ballroom where all his crowd, all his supporters are waiting. The place is absolutely packed. If you watch clips of this on YouTube, it's unbelievable how they, not only that they've managed to fit so many people into the ballroom, but the platform, this
他坐在套房的地板上，非常具有罗伯特·肯尼迪、1960年代的风格，非常时髦，盘腿坐在地板上抽着雪茄。更时髦的是，他们随后下楼去唱伍迪·格思里的歌。是的。于是他下楼来到舞厅，那里所有的群众、所有的支持者都在等待。现场绝对挤满了人。如果你在YouTube上观看这方面的剪辑，你会觉得难以置信，他们不仅设法把这么多人塞进舞厅，而且那个平台，
kind of dace at the end of the room, is absolutely stuffed with people singing Woody Guthrie songs. So Kennedy pushes his way onto the platform. He's surrounded by people. He's almost dwarfed by all these people. It's an ecstatic reception. People are screaming and shouting. It's now two minutes past midnight. And Kennedy declares victory. We've won in California. Brilliant. He gives the speech that you would expect. He says, we can end the divisions in the United States between black and white. We're a great country and a selfish country, a compassionate country. I'm going to make this my basis for running. We want to deal with these problems and we want peace in Vietnam. So my thanks to all of you and on to Chicago
房间尽头的这个舞台，挤满了唱歌的伍迪·格思里的粉丝。于是肯尼迪挤上了讲台。他被人群包围着。他几乎被所有这些人淹没了。现场是一片狂热的欢迎。人们在尖叫呐喊。现在刚过午夜两分钟。肯尼迪宣布胜利。我们在加利福尼亚获胜了。太棒了。他发表了人们所期望的演讲。他说，我们可以消除美国在黑人和白人之间的分歧。我们是一个伟大的国家，也是一个自私的国家、一个富有同情心的国家。我将把这作为我参选的基础。我们要解决这些问题，我们想要越南实现和平。因此，感谢大家，向芝加哥进发，
and let's win there. And then he gives a V sign, peace, but also victory. And now he turns to go. Now the plan is to go out to a second rally on a lower floor where an overspill crowd of supporters are waiting. And then to go into an annex where there's a load of pressmen and there's going to be a press conference. In the chaos as he leaves the stage because it's so crowded, his campaign manager shouts in his ear and says, it's too crowded and it's so late, we will skip the second rally and we'll go straight to the press conference. And they push their way out through the back of the ballroom, through these swinging doors
让我们在那里取得胜利。然后他比了一个V字手势，代表和平，也代表胜利。现在他转身准备离开。计划是去楼下一个较小的集会现场，那里有一大群溢出的支持者在等待。然后去一个附属房间，那里有一大群新闻记者，将要举行一场记者招待会。在他离开舞台的混乱中，由于人多拥挤，他的竞选经理在他耳边大喊：“人太多了，而且太晚了，我们跳过第二场集会，直接去记者招待会。”他们从舞厅的后方挤出去，穿过这些弹簧门
into the hotel kitchen. It's unbelievably crowded. And in the crush behind him, Kennedy is separated from his bodyguard. His bodyguard is helping Ethel, who is heavily pregnant, off the platform. But he's got all his team around him. They continue to sort of push into the kitchen.
进入酒店厨房。这里拥挤得难以置信。在他身后的拥挤人群中，肯尼迪与他的保镖失散了。他的保镖正在护送怀有身孕的埃塞尔离开讲台。但他的周围都是他的团队。他们继续挤进厨房。
They're almost carried along by this great sort of wave of people, a huge mob of photographers behind them. The kitchens are full of the kitchen, they're almost carried along by this great sort of wave of people, a huge mob of photographers behind them. The kitchens are full of the kitchen staff who have waited because they get a glimpse of, you know, America's most famous political celebrity. And as they go through the kitchen, Kennedy is reaching to shake hands. They go through into a kind of corridor, sort of pantry style corridor. There's an ice machine. There's a row of heated steel cupboards. It's just yards to go now until the room where the newspaper men are waiting. As they say in an American melodrama, the Sunday Times guys, it was
他们几乎被这股巨大的人潮、身后的一大群摄影师给簇拥着往前走。厨房里挤满了厨房员工，他们等在这里是为了能瞥一眼美国最著名的政治名流。当他们穿过厨房时，肯尼迪伸手去和大家握手。他们穿过一个走廊，类似于食品室风格的走廊。那里有一台制冰机。有一排加热的钢制橱柜。距离记者们等待的房间只有几码远了。正如《星期日泰晤士报》的人在一本美国情景剧中所说的那样，它
like an alleyway in a ship. It was like the corridor of the Titanic or something. It's got naked metal, cooking smells, yellow light. It's very kind of unsettling atmosphere and packed with people. As Kennedy passes through into this room a radio journalist is asking him about the fact that he's so far behind Humphrey in the delegate count and he's turning his head to talk to this guy. At the same time he's reaching out in another direction to shake hands with a Mexican busboy or as you would say in English a kitchen assistant called Juan Romero. And at this
就像一艘船上的小巷。就像泰坦尼克号的走廊什么的。那里有裸露的金属、烹饪的油烟、黄色的灯光。这是一种非常让人不安的氛围，而且挤满了人。当肯尼迪穿过这个房间时，一名广播记者正在问他关于他在代表票数上远远落后于汉弗莱的事实，他转过头去和这个人说话。与此同时，他向另一个方向伸出手去和一名墨西哥杂工握手，或者用英语说就是一个名叫胡安·罗梅罗的厨房助理。就在这个
point as he's reaching out, somebody pushes through the crowd and this is a young man who has been waiting there all this time. People say he was wearing a blue sweatshirt and he had what they called a sickly expression on his face. And the young man is holding a gun and he fires. A number of shots, how many is contested. There is a huge melee. People are piling onto this bloke, throwing themselves onto him, get the gun, get the gun. The radio reporters are recording this. So we have the audio footage of people screaming and shouting, get the gun, break his fingers, get the gun. Kennedy had fallen back against the ice machine and then he's down on the floor. He's still conscious and his eyes are open, but people see there is blood coming out from behind his ear. Juan Romero, the
时候，当他把手伸出去时，有人从人群中挤了过来，这是一个一直在那里等候的年轻男子。人们说他穿着一件蓝色运动衫，脸上带着一种病态的表情。这个年轻人手里拿着一把枪，开枪了。开了几枪？具体数字存在争议。现场一片大乱。人们扑向这家伙，把他扑倒在地，夺下枪，夺下枪。广播记者正在录音。所以我们有人们尖叫呐喊的音频资料：“夺下枪，折断他的手指，夺下枪。”肯尼迪向后倒在制冰机上，然后倒在地板上。他仍然有意识，眼睛睁着，但人们看到血从他的耳后流出来。胡安·罗梅罗，那个
Mexican busboy, drops to his side and Kennedy says to him, whispers, is everybody okay? Romero, yes, everybody's okay. But now the blood is absolutely flooding out from behind Kennedy's ear. In fact, what has happened is that he has been shot three times, once in the head and twice in his back. Five other people were shot too in the chaos, reporters and campaign volunteers, but none of them injured so badly. Romero reaches into his pocket and gets out some rosary beads and presses them into Kennedy's hand and he cradles his head and his hand is now covered with blood because
墨西哥杂工，扑到他身旁，肯尼迪对他说，低声问道：“大家都还好吗？”罗梅罗回答：“是的，大家都还好。”但现在鲜血正从肯尼迪的耳后疯狂涌出。事实上，发生的事情是他中三枪，头部一枪，背部两枪。在混乱中还有另外五个人中枪，包括记者和竞选志愿者，但他们的伤势都没有那么重。罗梅罗把手伸进口袋掏出一串玫瑰念珠，塞进肯尼迪手里，他托起肯尼迪的头，此时他的手上已经沾满鲜血，因为
there's so much blood coming from his head. Ethel is now caught up with her husband and she's crying and she says give him room to breathe, give him room to breathe and then she whispers to Robert Kennedy, I'm with you, I'm with you my baby. One of Kennedy's friends who was a journalist called Pete Hamill said at this point that Kennedy had this strange smile on his face like he was very... A kind of sweet, accepting smile. Yeah, exactly. Then there are paramedics pushing their way through the crowd and the paramedics are straight
他的头部流了好多血。埃塞尔现在追上了她的丈夫，她在哭泣，她说给他留点呼吸的空间，给他留点呼吸的空间，然后她对罗伯特·肯尼迪耳语道，我和你在一起，我和你在一起，我的宝贝。肯尼迪的一位记者朋友皮特·哈米尔这时说，肯尼迪脸上有一种奇怪的微笑，好像非常……一种甜美、接受的微笑。是的，一点没错。接着，有急救人员从人群中挤进来，急救人员径直
to his side and they immediately try to lift him to get him out. And at that, Kennedy says, he just says very quietly, oh no, don't lift me. And those are the last words he ever says because he passes out. So Kennedy is taken out of the hotel and rushed to the, eventually to the Good Samaritan Hospital. And news flashes around the country. I will just say this. McCarthy is in his hotel room writing his concession speech and his campaign
来到他身边，立刻试图将他抬起来带走。就在这时，肯尼迪说，他非常轻声地说道：“哦，不，不要抬我。”这些是他说的最后一句话，因为他昏迷了。于是肯尼迪被抬出酒店，紧急送往——最终送到善良撒玛利亚人医院。消息传遍全国。我只想说这个。麦卡锡在酒店房间里写他的退选演讲，他的竞选
manager told me that when the news reached McCarthy that Kennedy had been shot, his first reaction was to say he brought it upon himself. A day goes by, the nation is waiting, people are stunned and shocked by this. But it's not until the 6th at 2 o'clock in the morning that Kennedy's press secretary comes out of the hospital, and again you can see it on YouTube,, absolutely stricken and he says to the waiting reporters that he has died. In fact, he had effectively died. When he was shot like his brother.
经理告诉我，当麦卡锡得知肯尼迪中枪的消息时，他的第一反应是说这是他咎由自取。一天过去了，全国上下都在等待，人们对此感到震惊和错愕。直到6日凌晨两点，肯尼迪的新闻秘书才从医院出来，同样你可以在YouTube上看到，他显得悲痛欲绝，对等待的记者们说他已经去世了。事实上，他当时就已经差不多死了。就像他的兄弟一样，他被枪击时就
Exactly. And indeed like Martin Luther King. Now to compare it with the shootings of John F Kennedy and Martin Luther King, one difference is that we know precisely who the gunman was beyond any possible doubt, because the people threw themselves on top of him at the time and fought to get the gun out of his hand. He was 24 years old and he was called Sahan Sahan. He was Palestinian, born in Jerusalem in 1944. Not as you often read, a Palestinian Muslim, but a Palestinian Christian.
相当于已经死了。没错。确实就像马丁·路德·金一样。现在，将它与约翰·F·肯尼迪和马丁·路德·金遭枪击事件进行比较，其中一个区别是，我们毫无疑问地确切知道枪手是谁，因为当时人们扑在他身上，拼命想把枪从他手里夺下来。他当时24岁，名叫索罕·索罕。他是巴勒斯坦人，1944年出生于耶路撒冷。不像你经常读到的那样，他不是巴勒斯坦穆斯林，而是巴勒斯坦基督徒。
He said later that he had been traumatized by the war of the late 1940s, that his brother had been run over by an Israeli military vehicle. I guess it's just about possible he might just remember the late 1940s if you're four or five years old. His family had moved to the United States when he was 12 and he'd been to school in Los Angeles. He was very short and slight and a loner, a drifter. He'd been in and out of various churches. He'd been a Baptist, a Seventh-day Adventist. He'd even been a Rosicrucian, would you believe? So all these people are drifters.
他后来称，自己曾受到20世纪40年代末战争的创伤，他的兄弟曾被以色列军车碾压。我想，如果你当时四五岁的话，你可能还依稀记得40年代末的事情。他12岁时随家人移居美国，在洛杉矶上过学。他个子很矮，身材瘦弱，是个独行侠、四处飘泊的人。他去过不同的教堂。他当过浸信会教徒、基督复临安息日会教徒。你敢信，他甚至还当过玫瑰十字会会员。所以这些人都是四处漂泊的人。
Yeah, well, there's a pattern, right? The assassins. Of course. Sohan Sohan said later that he had been radicalized, as it were, by the Six-Day War of 1967, which had begun exactly one year before the day he assassinated Robert Kennedy. He later told David Frost in an interview that he shot Kennedy because of, quote,
对啊，这里有个模式，对吧？这些刺客。当然。索罕·索罕后来表示，他可以说是被1967年的六日战争激进化的，这场战争开始于他刺杀罗伯特·肯尼迪整整一年前的那一天。他后来在接受大卫·弗罗斯特采访时表示，他枪击肯尼迪是因为，引述他的话说，
his support for Israel and his deliberate attempt to send 50 fighter jets to Israel to obviously do harm to the Palestinians. And we know that he wrote in his diary about his determination to eliminate RFK, Kennedy must die before June the 5th. The reason is because he wants to shoot Kennedy to mark the anniversary of the Six Day War. Again, amazing. Another parallel with 2024, the salience of the war in Israel and Gaza. Exactly, as providing a kind of background to what's going on. He admitted his guilt straight away and he was sentenced to death.
他对以色列的支持，以及他试图向以色列运送50架战斗机以蓄意伤害巴勒斯坦人的行为。我们知道他在日记中写下了除掉RFK的决心，肯尼迪必须在6月5日之前死去。原因是他想在枪击肯尼迪以纪念六日战争周年。再次令人惊叹。这与2024年的又一个平行点是，以色列和加沙战争的重要性。没错，它为正在发生的事情提供了一种背景。他立刻承认了自己的罪行，并被判处死刑。
That sentence was commuted to life imprisonment when California scrapped the death penalty, and then he decided that he wasn't guilty after all and said that actually he'd been framed or he'd been brainwashed or whatever. You know, I said that that director. Kind of Manchurian candidate thing again another weird link there that the main conspiracy theory as far as I can tell I mean there are lots of different conspiracy theories about Sahant but one of the most popular is that he was in some way part of a CIA experiment and
当加州废除死刑时，他的刑期被减为无期徒刑，随后他决定自己其实并没有罪，并说实际上自己是被陷害了、被洗脑了之类的。你知道，我之前说过那个导演……那种满洲候选人的桥段，又是一个奇怪的联系。据我所知，关于索罕的主要阴谋论有很多，但最流行的一种是，他在某种程度上是中情局实验的一部分，并
had been brainwashed and that this was all a CIA plot to kill Kennedy. I don't want to offend listeners who believe it, but I have to say, I regarded as totally untrue. Sohan Sohan is still alive. He's 80 years old as is Ethel Kennedy is still alive. As is Ethel, yeah, 96. Sohan Sohan has made 17 different appeals for parole, which have all been turned down in 2021. He had an unexpected support. All the Kennedy children said, please don't let this guy out, except one. That was RFK Jr., the eccentric erstwhile presidential candidate who said, no, no,
被洗脑了，这一切都是中情局刺杀肯尼迪的阴谋。我不想冒犯相信这一点的听众，但我必须说，我认为这完全是无稽之谈。索罕·索罕还活着。他已经80岁了，埃塞尔·肯尼迪也还活着。埃塞尔也活着，是的，96岁了。索罕·索罕已经进行了17次假释上诉，但全部被驳回。2021年，他得到了一个意料之外的支持。所有的肯尼迪孩子都说，请不要放这个人出来，只有一个例外。那就是小罗伯特·肯尼迪（RFK Jr.），这位古怪的前总统候选人，他说，不，不，
I support his campaign, let him out. But they didn't. The final question, what if, you know, the great question of Kennedy's life. When he was taken out of the kitchen, the journalists noticed that somebody had scrawled graffiti on one of the walls. They didn't know it was a coincidence or what it was. They had scrawled the words, the once and future king. So that's a Camelot illusion. Camelot illusion.
我支持他的竞选，放了他吧。但他们没有。最后一个问题，如果……你知道，肯尼迪一生中最大的假设。当他被抬出厨房时，记者们注意到有人在其中一面墙上乱涂乱画。他们不知道这只是巧合还是什么。他们涂画的词是：昔日与未来的国王。所以这是一个卡米洛特的隐喻。卡米洛特的隐喻。
King Arthur. Exactly. And that's his enduring reputation among liberal Democrats, I think, or 60s veterans, that he is the great loss leader, the martyr, the champion of the underdog. And if he had lived, maybe everything would have been different. That this is a real turning point in history and that the political course of American life... Do you think that resonance would be even higher, you know, if he'd been shot by a white supremacist or somebody from a less marginalized background than a Palestinian.
亚瑟王。没错。我认为这正是他在自由派民主党人或60年代老兵心目中永恒的声誉，他是伟大的失利领袖、烈士、底层人民的斗士。如果他活下来，也许一切都会不同。这可以说是美国历史上真正的转折点，美国政治走向……你认为，如果他是被白人至上主义者或来自不那么边缘化背景的人而不是巴勒斯坦人枪杀，这种共鸣会不会更高呢？
Yeah. I mean, it would be a better story, right? It would be a more Hollywood ending. It would have more resonance, wouldn't it? Because Martin Luther King is shot by a white supremacist. Yes, he is. And that obviously amplifies the kind of the resonance of his fate. Yeah, I agree with you. As it is, and I know a lot of listeners, American listeners in particular, disagree with me about this. I don't think there was any prospect of him being president in 1968. First of all, I think it's incredibly unlikely that he would have been the Democratic nominee. So many people didn't like him in the party. I think it's highly implausible that he would ever
对。我的意思是，那会是一个更好的故事，对吧？那会是一个更具好莱坞风格的结局。会有更多共鸣，不是吗？因为马丁·路德·金就是被白人至上主义者枪杀的。是的，他是。这显然放大了他的命运所引发的共鸣。是的，我同意你的看法。就目前而言，我知道许多听众，尤其是美国听众不同意我的看法。我不认为他在1968年有任何当选总统的可能。首先，我认为他根本不可能成为民主党候选人。党内有太多人不喜欢他。我认为他永远
have overhauled Humphrey's lead among the delegates and defied the union leaders and the city bosses and people who generally controlled the convention. If he had been the nominee, again, I know a lot of listeners would agree with this, I think Nixon would have beaten him in 1968 in the general election. And even if he had then run in 1972, or if he'd just run in 1972, I think Nixon would have beaten him in 1972 as well. And I think the reason is that Americans craved order and stability. And a lot of middle America would have seen Kennedy as a threat to those things, rather than as the answer to their problems.
不可能在代表中超过汉弗莱的领先优势，去对抗工会领袖、城市大佬以及那些通常控制代表大会的人。如果他成为了候选人，同样，我知道很多听众会同意这一点，我认为尼克松会在1968年的大选中击败他。即使他接着在1972年参选，或者哪怕他只在1972年参选，我认为尼克松在1972年也会击败他。我认为原因在于美国人渴望秩序和稳定。许多美国中产阶级会把肯尼迪视为对这些事物的威胁，而不是他们问题的答案。
And I think the thing that people often say is you're discounting the Kennedy mystique, the Kennedy celebrity. But he'd already lost one election to McCarthy, who's not exactly the best candidate in the world. And what is more, his brother Ted, if you believe in the Kennedy mystique, the Kennedy celebrity, but he'd already lost one election to McCarthy who's not exactly the best candidate in the world. And what is more, his brother Ted, if you believe in the Kennedy Mystique, his brother Ted couldn't even beat Jimmy Carter in the Democratic primaries in 1980. But he was very damaged goods by that point. He was, but if Tom, I think if you can't beat Jimmy Carter in 1980, you can't beat anyone, frankly. I know that sounds very harsh. I don't want to stamp on Carter. Anyway, because
我认为人们经常说的一点是，你低估了肯尼迪的神秘感和名人效应。但他已经输给过麦卡锡一次选举了，而麦卡锡可算不上世界上最好的候选人。更何况，他的弟弟特德——如果你相信肯尼迪的神秘感和名人效应的话——他的弟弟特德在1980年的民主党初选中甚至都赢不了吉米·卡特。但那时候他已经是名誉受损的人了。他是，但汤姆，我想如果你在1980年连吉米·卡特都赢不了，坦白说你谁也赢不了。我知道这听起来很刺耳。我不想贬低卡特。无论如何，因为
I think there'll be lots of people who say, I think that's rubbish. I think Kennedy could have won. And maybe we can discuss this in a bonus episode at some point for our club members. So LBJ is out. Martin Luther King has been murdered. Robert Kennedy has been murdered and we're not even halfway through the year. So there's a lot to come. We have the Chicago convention.
我想会有很多人说，我觉得这是胡说八道。我认为肯尼迪本可以赢。也许我们可以在日后为我们的俱乐部会员做一期特别节目来讨论这个。所以LBJ退出了。马丁·路德·金被谋杀。罗伯特·肯尼迪也被谋杀，而这一年还没过半。所以接下来还有很多事。我们有芝加哥党代会。
We have the campaign convention. We have the campaign of George Wallace, the new populism, and we have one of the great comebacks in American history, the return from the dead of the ultimate Lazarus, Richard Milhouse Nixon. Well, that is exciting. But next episode we'll be with the Yippies. So Yippie for that. And you can hear it straight away if you want to by signing up at therestishistory.com and you'll be able to hear all the rest of the series. If you don't want to, fine.
我们有竞选大会。我们有乔治·华莱士的竞选，新的民粹主义，我们还有美国历史上最伟大的东山再起之一，终极拉撒路理查德·米尔豪斯·尼克松的死而复生。嗯，这真令人兴奋。但下一期节目我们将和嬉皮士们一起。所以为此欢呼吧。如果你想立刻收听，只需在therestishistory.com注册，你就能听到该系列的所有其余内容。如果你不想听，也没关系。
It will be coming in due course and we will be back very soon. Missing you already. Goodbye. Goodbye. Hello everybody, Dominic here. Now I have some very good news for you because if you've been enjoying the series that we're doing on America in 1968 and my tangled relationship with Eugene McCarthy, the news couldn't be better actually because on Tuesday the 5th of November, thrilling news for people who like American politics, I will be covering the American presidential election through
节目随后就会推出，我们很快就会回来。已经开始想念你们了。再见。再见。大家好，我是多米尼克。现在我有一个非常好的消息要告诉大家，如果你一直喜欢我们制作的关于1968年美国的系列节目以及我和尤金·麦卡锡之间纠结的关系，那消息简直不能再好了，因为在11月5日星期二，对于喜欢美国政治的人来说这是一个激动人心的消息，我将从纽约市现场直播报道美国总统大选
the night, live from New York City. Now, the downside of this for people who enjoy very poor American accents and stories about the Punic Wars, the Bannies, if you're one of that sort of embattled minority, Tom Holland will not be joining us. He's not allowed to come. I will be joined by, unbelievably, Rory Stewart and Alistair Campbell from The Rest Is Politics, Anthony Scaramucci from The Rest Is Politics US and Marina Hyde from The Rest Is Entertainment.
通宵节目。现在，对于喜欢非常糟糕的美国口音和布匿战争、巴尼人故事的人来说，这是个缺点——如果你是那种备受围攻的少数群体之一，汤姆·霍兰将不会加入我们。他不能来。令人难以置信的是，加入我的将有来自《历史其余部分》的罗里·斯图尔特和阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔，来自《美国历史其余部分》的安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，以及来自《娱乐其余部分》的玛丽娜·海德。
Alan Shearer from the Rest is Football was invited but he didn't want to come. We will be live on YouTube from 3pm Eastern time on Tuesday afternoon and we'll be back again dementedly at midnight, terrifying prospect, to take you through the early hours of Wednesday morning. We will be analysing all the events as they unfold I read. We will be analyzing all the events as they unfold, I read. We will be comparing 2024 to elections past in American history, and we'll be reacting to the unveiling of the next president of the United States. Now, I know that Rest is History listeners are not necessarily the same persuasion
来自《足球其余部分》的阿兰·希勒也受到了邀请，但他不想来。我们将在星期二下午东部时间下午3点开始在YouTube上进行直播，并且我们将在午夜再次疯狂回归——这是一个可怕的前景——陪你度过周三清晨的早期时光。我读到，我们将分析所有不断发展的事件。我们读到，我们将分析所有正在展开的事件。我们将把2024年与美国历史上的历次选举进行比较，并对下一任美国总统的揭晓做出反应。现在，我知道《历史其余部分》的听众不一定和
as those of our sister podcasts. So to allay your fears for every mention of Donald Trump or Boris Johnson that Alastair Campbell makes, I will ensure that viewers get at least six anecdotes about Hubert Humphrey or George Wallace. For more information, why wouldn't you want more information on such a galaxy of stars? Just search for The Rest Is Politics America Decides on YouTube. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的姊妹播客听众有相同的政治倾向。因此，为了消除你们的担忧，阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔每提到一次唐纳德·特朗普或鲍里斯·约翰逊，我就会确保观众至少能听到六个关于于贝尔·汉弗莱或乔治·华莱士的趣闻轶事。欲了解更多信息，为什么你不想了解这样一个全明星阵容的更多信息呢？只需在YouTube上搜索《历史其余部分：美国抉择》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。